thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
yes sir
the Lord's Day
Sunday Sunday Super Bowl Sunday at that
talk to the round what's going on
pop now let's do a little roll call
popping out what's up okay Gerald Mack
okay I see you all hail the IOP salute
you know what I'm saying you know the
cogs off kick David Lord adding some
more days people respect we gotta keep
it very respectful let me see how my
levels are doing hustle and motivator I
see you you've been rocking them to fly
tracks man I'll be seeing them tracks on
the timeline hustle you really got a
nice Vibe going on on them tracks man I
gotta get that playlist
what's going on chris713 what's going on
good morning
lydian Master pre-game of Super Bowl you
already know it doesn't get any better
than iot humbled humble salute Robert
Kelly hey guys happy Super Bowl Sunday
salute salute Isaac Gentry what's going
on Lord Metro we got Nintendo topics I
don't wanna hear no lip
thank you sir I appreciate you hustle I
won't have no lip Floyd Metro y'all or
the Nintendo switch coming in hot I
always be the one that tried to get a
Nintendo topic on but there's three
other Lords that uh usually pick other
topics but I look like we got that
covered today so we're here now
james176 what's up we're about to get
the legendary Max Castillo Big Time Maca
up and become a comedian killing The
Tick Tock game killing the Instagram
game he's doing his thing y'all doing
this thing he play some games too black
conflict X what's going on power to the
people brother I see you
what's going on dot otaku Ted dollars to
the heck of the Nintendo
before its sixth year has amazing sales
numbers posted for the quarter but the
topic is about the only somewhat
negative media bias against Nintendo
continues but I'll tell you who did the
70 Target oh that was um that was king
that's okay he did that one but uh we
got Nintendo topics man you know what
I'm saying so yeah shout out to the
switch they did their thing and um
that's my that's my number one traffic
and I'm just coming from a Sega kid I
told people to switch this gonna do that
but uh they didn't listen they said it
was gonna be a fad no who's gonna buy it
I remember the comments they were like
who's gonna buy that no one wants that
and I remember seeing that commercial
and being like yeah that's me I'm the
guy that you know what I'm saying
that'll pick it up good jump on a plane
dock it into the hotel room I was that
dude so I knew they were speaking to me
so uh yeah but we're gonna get into a
lot of Nintendo techno love and all that
good stuff also got to talk about how it
works and all of that controversy a
little bit what's going on and then um
yeah we're gonna have some fun man we
got Big Time mocking the building
waiting for him to get in here and uh
we're gonna talk about his journey his
gaming you know what I'm saying and then
get into it appreciate y'all early up in
here we're gonna go get the king I spoke
to him earlier addict might be running
like a few minutes late but uh it's all
gonna be coming through too but we're
gonna have the Full House all the Lords
on the Lord's day good to see y'all talk
y'all in a minute
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know started I
am well it's not important who I am uh
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron Lords podcast right now
as we speaking uh I guess I'm here to
keep you entertained until it's time to
get this show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and headers be swearing ain't
real but coming to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah I'll be using
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beating they want to compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and snapping and making it flammable
this is that this is that Yoga Fire
Flame they think it's Arsen up in the
apartment they call it department and I
get the blame still I'll be running
collecting them Reigns you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless back when you was
messaging people on AIM check my vocals
all on Twitter but I'm anti-social or my
CD but I'm still by Coastal I got it
[Music]
because it's pretty hard to sleep on
Freddy Krueger that's whoo
let's do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on the
song with me that's understandable I
kill a beating they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original you're also Dramatical I
know it's random but I'm addicted to
flipping and Snapple and making it
flammable this is that this is that Yoga
Fire Flame they think it's Arsen up in
the apartment they call a department and
I get the blame still I'll be running
collecting them Reigns you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless back when you was
messaging people on AIM check my vocals
all on Twitter but I'm anti-social or my
city but I'm still by Coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell an Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
down look You Oughta messed up and
turned me to an animal and hell is be
swearing ain't real but come to find out
that they really mechanical and yeah
I'll be eating these rappers but that's
all a part of me being a cannibal and
they say I'm better than money because
you can Bank on me being accountable I
know a million rappers they don't want
to be on a song with me that's
understandable why killer beating they
wanna compare me to Freddie and Jason
I'd rather be Hannibal they'd be like
why use a video game just be original
y'all too Dramatical I know it's random
but I'm addicted to flipping and
sampling making it flammable this is
that this is the Yoga Fire Flame they
think it's Arsen up in the apartment
they call a department and I get the
blame still I'll be running collecting
the rain you just a Target when I'm in
the range I was the hardest to start
regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social or my city but I'm still by
Coastal I got you man
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell her Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
down look y'all messed up and turned me
to an animal and headers be swearing
ain't real but come to find out that
they really mechanical and yeah I'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being a cannibal and they say
I'm better than money because you can
Bank on me being accountable I know a
million rappers that don't want to be on
a song with me that's understandable I
kill a beat and they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
for the original you also Dramatical I
know it's random but I'm addicted to
flipping and Snapple and making it
flammable this is that this is the Yoga
Fire Flame they think it's Arsen up in
the apartment they call a department and
I get the blame still I'll be running
collecting them Reigns you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless like we was
messaging people don't aim check my
vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social lower my city but I'm still
by Coastal I got you man
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell an Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important to who I am uh what's
important is that you are pulling up to
the iron Lords podcast right now as we
speaking uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
down
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and headers be swearing ain't
real but coming to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah I'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being a cannibal and they say
I'm better than money because you can
Bank on me being accountable I know a
million rappers that don't want to be on
a song with me that's understandable I
kill a beat and they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original you're also Dramatical I
know it's random but I'm addicted to
flipping and Sample and making it
flammable this is that this is that Yoga
Fire Flame they think it's Arsen up in
the apartment they call it department
and I get the blame still I'll be
running collecting them rain you just a
Target when I'm in the range I was the
hardest to start it regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social knowing my city but I'm
still by Coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell her Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
[Music]
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original you're also Dramatical I
know it's random but I'm addicted to
flipping and Snapple and making it
flammable this is that this is that Yoga
Fire Flame they think it's Arsen up in
the apartment they call a department and
I get the blame still I'll be running
collecting them Reigns you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless back when you was
messaging people on AIM check my vocals
all on Twitter but I'm anti-social or my
city but I'm still by Coastal
[Music]
because it's pretty hard to sleep on
Freddy Krueger that's oh
let's do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot to get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
[Music]
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beating they wanna compare me to Freddie
and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal they'd
be like why use a video game just be
original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and sampling making it flammable this is
that this is the Yoga Fire Flame they
think it's Arsen up in the apartment
they call a department and I get the
blame still I'll be running collecting
them Reigns you just a Target when I'm
in the range I was the hardest to start
regardless of people don't aim check my
vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social or my city but I'm still by
Coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell an Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on the
song with me that's understandable I
kill a beating they want to compare me
to Freddie and Jason I'd rather be
Hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original y'all too
Dramatical I know it's random but I'm
addicted to flipping and snapping and
making it flammable this is that this is
that Yoga Fire Flame they think it's
Arsen up in the apartment they call it
department and I get the blame still
I'll be running collecting them Reigns
you just a Target when I'm in the range
I was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people on
AIM check my vocals all on Twitter but
I'm anti-social or my city but I'm still
by Coastal I got it
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell her Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
[Music]
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable why can't
it be and they want to compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and snapping and making it flammable
this is that this is that Yoga Fire
Flame they think it's Arsen up in the
apartment they call it department and I
get the blame still I'll be running
collecting the rain you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless back when you was
messaging people on AIM check my vocals
all on Twitter but I'm anti-social or my
city but I'm still by Coastal I got
[Music]
because it's pretty hard to sleep on
Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original you're also Dramatical I
know it's random but I'm addicted to
flipping and Snapple and making it
flammable this is that this is that Yoga
Fire Flame they think it's arson up in
the apartment they call it department
and I get the blame still I'll be
running collecting them Reigns you just
a Target when I'm in the range I was the
hardest to start regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social or my city but I'm still by
Coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell an Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important to who I am uh what's
important is that you are pulling up to
the iron Lords podcast right now as we
speaking uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
down
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and headers be swearing ain't
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah I'll be using
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on the
song with me that's understandable I
kill a beat and they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original you're also Dramatical I
know it's random but I'm addicted to
flipping and snapping and making it
flammable this is that this is the Yoga
Fire Flame they think it's Arsen up in
the apartment they call a department and
I get the blame still I'll be running
collecting them Reigns you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless back when you was
messaging people on AIM check my vocals
all on Twitter but I'm anti-social or my
city but I'm still by Coastal I got it
um
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell her Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
[Music]
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and Snapple and making it flammable this
is that this is that Yoga Fire Flame
they think it's Arsen up in the
apartment they call a department and I
get the blame still I'll be running
collecting them rain you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social or my city but I'm still by
Coastal I got you man
[Music]
because it's pretty hard to sleep on
Freddy Krueger that's oh
let's do that again
[Music]
a problem
detrimental to an elemental what's an
avatar to an even though I gotta be me
though I know it's my destiny work to
carnito who cares if he fly if you steal
a mosquito you swear you ain't something
but really be Stevo you like to collect
stuff and that's cool but I got bad news
even if you really was that joke you
never still be the king of the statue
sister juvenile I've been cursed with a
curse to be Musical and if you hate it
we'll meet in The Crucible other than
nothing it's cool and it's beautiful we
let you know that your dreams are
pursuable whatever you want to do then
it's doable if you got work on a Sunday
it's suitable cause you can listen to
this and you're cubicle on the Lord's
day
if you got work on a Sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle on the Lord day
[Music]
Mike checking my check is off real quick
give me some vocals sir
we don't yeah we hot we hot back
[Laughter]
we good we good here you hear you and we
are live welcome to the iloos podcast
LLC and also live on lordsofgaming.net
episode number 291. it is a another
glorious Sunday we're back at the round
table on the Lord's date and today I'm
extremely excited about our special
guest and we've got Hogwarts Legacy the
latest Nintendo Direct 70 Zelda games
and MLB the Show 23 to discuss so we
gonna get right into it
I want to introduce the Lord whose
unique Fusion of stand-up sketch comedy
and video games has us all laughing at
producer tags and hilarious
impersonations with the best dance moves
in the game
introducing the comedian slash writer of
the big time marker Tick Tock Instagram
and YouTube channels the OG lord of the
golden now pause music bop
always have been my dad who's Tick-Tock
stayed lit self-shot self-edited
self-directed live from Scooby-Doo
making his debut into the realm of the
Lord my man Lord Max Castillo aka Big
Time Maca how we doing sir damn that was
the best intro I've ever gotten on
anything in my whole life thank you so
much
[__] great how are you how you doing
I wanted to ask you about the language
of the Lord today that's all you know
for the Little Lords that's cool you're
good I will refrain from sinning again
uh thanks for having me on I'm pumped no
doubt no doubt man you are Lord in your
realm big fan of what you do I know
you've been doing your comedy one have
you got a chance to play any games
lately sir what you been playing I've
been so it's hard being an adult and
being busy I'm still working my way
through God of War Ragnarok
um uh and then I played a little bit of
uh I like extreme sports games and we're
kind of in this weird Indie Renaissance
for them so I've been playing Project
session and Shredder skateboard game but
right now yeah still kind of working my
way through God of War Ragnarok uh
loving that absolute blast boy how you
feeling there boy
you moving moving good with it
yeah it's it's it's nice I liked uh I
was a really big fan of the first one I
was kind of nervous with the first one
because I was like oh like it's gonna be
too different I don't know and it was
absolutely it was so fun it was so well
done
but obviously yeah boy yeah
everything everything yeah you gotta
respect respect to Mr judgment they did
that man great game cool that you're
playing got time now playing all that
good stuff and uh yeah man we got some
other Lords uh supposedly in the Realms
of I see someone then pulled up in the
cut I don't know if that if his bike is
good what's going on is that addict
I had to drive down the road real quick
so
um
glad to see you and of course we got
when we don't got four horsepower just
yet we got three but we're gonna get
another one the original Lord's here on
the realm in the round table my co-host
Nicole knows my brother from another
mother the difficult game conqueror Lord
of his old world and the how of the
young wolf my man pull it in very
graciously late Lord attic how we doing
sir
doing pretty good appreciate it for
coming through
uh it's it's uh I don't think he's
coming today
um he's posted in the chat only post up
on the chat okay I've been trying to see
what's going on in the chat okay what's
up yes I got a ball of you what's up
with the jacket with the chest
you got the chest on what's going on I
just I just sat down I think you're
about to go do like a a gig where you're
getting paid to strip
what am I seeing here yeah I was like
are we closed did this Atticus what's
going on yeah I got a shirt on okay I
was nervous you know that was the side I
just came I just came from outside it's
raining and snowing oh okay okay
not much I played a lot of
um Legacy uh Hogwarts Legacy no doubt
yeah and uh so I felt people were dming
me uh so I think I do have to address
that the tweet that uh the entire
Internet's been coming down on me
apparently yeah what's going on
apparently uh you know
it is see here here's the whole point of
the Tweet could I have uh worded it in a
better way sure I guess but
the thing I don't like is people coming
at me
uh subliminal shots there's been a lot
of people coming at me the past couple
days over like trying to put the wool
over the eyes kind of thing it's like
dude like you people could come at me
that's fine just like but we can't act
like there isn't issues in the industry
so what's that what's the main issue for
those who don't know a lot of people
don't know what you're talking about so
what's the main issue what was the tweet
that set off whatever that you that you
talking about
because it's just one of those things
where you know I posted saying uh I'm
gonna wait for people that I trust to
get the VR to because I know a lot of
people are just scared to upset Sony
like and what's funny is you you had the
the you had the PlayStation Fanboys
picking that tweet apart then you had
like people that got the VR thinking I'm
attacking them right and then it's just
like nah it's just like we go see her
and act like there hasn't been websites
to get uh to get pretty much blacklisted
from Sony just because they gave Horizon
a six out of five a six out of ten like
when I considered act like there isn't
incidences where multiple Outlets say
that they've been blacklisted by
companies like Bethesda like sometimes
like look sometimes these companies
these PR companies they do what they
they do what they do to keep their
business safe and it's like I get it
it's their job to protect the company
but at the same time it's not my job to
protect them
so it there's just there's just a lot of
stuff going on like a lot of the stuff
I've been seeing then it's just like you
know people want to forget when uh
cyberpunk came out and they were sniping
reviews that was saying it was bad
people want to forget that they want to
forget they was using the copyright
system to take down some reviews down
acting like that doesn't happen do we
remember the the
what's that place
uh uh the metal gear solid five remember
the the the the they would fly people
out there not let them leave the room
like yeah and then we know about the
cases of when the Embargo you sometimes
you know something's up when the Embargo
Tom is so close to like when the game's
gonna release and then it's like damn
why are we getting the chance to review
the game so late right so we don't get
enough time to really rock out so I
understand where you're coming from I
understand and it's just like one of
those things where you know it's like I
said maybe I could have worded that
better yeah or maybe it did seem more
aggressive towards individual people
that already had the VR too but it's
just like after I stated what I meant it
and people were still coming at me it is
what it is at that point no I feel that
because it's like you know it's one
thing to say yo addict I think you
should have worded this better you
should have had a better outcome it's
another thing to act like the issues
don't exist at all no I'll get you I get
your point and I think what it is is
probably like a misunderstanding is
people who may be personalizing it and
and you know it wasn't with that
intention you just wanted to make clear
that the issue exists kind of thing but
I'll see you but enough about beefing on
Twitter
um what you've been playing over there
we're gonna have more talk about even on
Twitter I see this is people on Twitter
Hogwarts legacies
I've been playing Hogwarts Legacy a lot
I'm actually really dived into that game
probably got about 10 hours into it no
doubt I still need to play more I just
past couple days have been just crazy I
haven't really had time to sit there and
play anything like it thoroughly nothing
I feel htk what's going on 360 I see you
bro no doubt no doubt and of course we
have our most technical gaming Lord the
solo gamer who lives for the single
player selfish experience and also the
substradamus the Lord of clarity and
Lord patreon of the iron bank my man the
smooth one what's up how are we doing
sir I'm good man I'm good I'm exhausted
I've been working since last night and
uh just craziness and I got to work
today so no no Super Bowl really for me
but uh
yeah you know it's not just my life but
you know but I did manage to get some
gaming in um miraculously so um like
like Maca I was uh I was out here
playing some of my God of War
yeah man yeah man oh yeah
it's I mean yeah man
a lot of people I like the side quest
stuff here like a lot of the side quests
stuff some of it can slow the pace down
of the game but that never really
bothers me
um but I just like the fact that it's
all kind of Story related and all sort
of makes sense within the the
overarching sort of story of the game so
it's just not random stuff or whatever
even if it is kind of a collect-a-thon
type thing it's still sort of associated
with the story in a cool way I haven't
seen one that I haven't really enjoyed
um or at least again it it always speaks
to a certain a character story arc or
something like that that kind of just
gives you more about those characters
and that's why those characters
ultimately they work
um so I'm enjoying it man I'm really
enjoying it
um I played a little bit of of Hogwarts
Legacy
um but not not too much uh my computer
did not arrive
um
so yeah because this is the thing like I
I pre-ordered I pre-ordered one of the
the Asus uh the Rog laptops right so it
didn't really say when they were coming
out they said they were supposed to
start coming out on the eighth right but
not until the eighth were they able to
give me an exact window for when for
when different uh different skus were
coming out so I believe the Asus ones
with the 4090s are like push in April
maybe I'm like oh nah I can't do that so
I had to I had to try to figure out
which one was coming as close as
possible with me as possible Right
within the next couple of weeks
um but what that did was it had to I had
to raise the price oh brother all right
that price is wow I'm ashamed to say
wait what you did
pretty bro it's not good what you blew
the whole check
will be eating ramen noodles we eating
ramen noodles this week what are we
doing oh yeah it's not good it's not
good but I hopefully I'll have it within
the next two weeks oh man all right but
it I mean all the specs that you saw and
now we're talking like 128 gigs of RAM
of I know how you do four terabyte hard
drive yeah it's just that was I can't
wait like yeah yeah yeah freaked me out
so I know I just gotta do I gotta do but
yeah so that's painful
what else what else what else Oh that's
oh Metroid Prime remastered bro he did
that
yo that game is like another game yeah
they did that I was like too it's one of
those things that a remake is supposed
to make you feel the Nostalgia for how
you felt when you played it originally
right and you you think oh yeah it
looked like this this is how it ran or
whatever now mind you make sure Prime
movies ran at 60. it was always a 60 FPS
game
um but you obviously the resolution
wasn't there but again in your mind it's
always this beautiful thing when they
put side by side they put the GameCube
the Wii and the switch version side by
side it's like they rebuilt that game
for the ground up straight up the switch
version is on another level
um so yeah that that was it was very
cool to see so I jumped back into that
and just yeah I mean retro did it with
with Metroid Prime it was the impossible
task of trying to figure out how to put
Metroid into the first person's face and
it really did it yeah so yeah I got the
game a little bit and it got got
their games out there
it's good to hear good to hear so um and
of course unfortunately the Incredible
Hulk is missing of this yes
he will not be here today just we just
got the word he's now Brothers not doing
well send some love he hates what I say
this but send some love love to King
make sure he's doing all right man
because he's not feeling well going
through something right now send some
love to the bro you know what I mean but
um yeah we will get better we'll get him
back in the realm as soon as he is
feeling better but of course we still
have the gaming ninja himself the
Shinobi Lord Cognito spreading that real
into the Roman IOP not telling what you
want to hear but what you need to hear
shout out to the father dude shout out
to Mr Maddie plays had a good one
talking about the Activision Blizzard uh
deal situation and then we got some
weird writings about people microwaving
Oreos fam yeah what's going on yeah man
that was close
what's good with your life what's good
about National Oreos in the in the in
the milk like this is real Penitentiary
like Behavior you know it is
what what are they making the toilets
they make like
wine in the toilet yeah like bro what's
going on I love the lsf fair [__] I
gotta relax some of y'all that door the
Lord's work with these Oreos yeah I'm
listening to this disgusted like I'm
like this this is what my patreon
[Laughter]
shout out to the last word we did a good
one we bought this tiger Travis had my
homegirl Sammy Cat on talking about life
for all the new stuff coming on to the
new expansion so we get that as far as
me with gaming uh B Hi-Fi Rush beat high
five Rush this week man I got a lot to
say man they yo Tango Game Works John
Johannes makami Bethesda y'all did that
y'all did that like it's so good I'm
like damn I want a hip-hop what it is
like you know the way they really you
know the game is to The Backs like the
game is to the to the beat and it's like
the whole world is influenced by the
music characters and it's not one of
them games because usually you hear like
rhythm game and you'd be like oh if I
mess up I can't beat it or it's not like
that it's more
additive it's more of a bonus if you do
it as opposed to we're going to restrict
you from doing it and I think that's why
what makes it work across the board you
have so many people saying that they
don't play Rhythm games but they play
this because they don't have to worry
about staying on the beat they could
just enjoy the game they can play like a
straight up beat em up and and that's
fine yeah see that was smart that was so
smart the boss fight it looks like an
anime it looks like it's straight out of
a cartoon it's fun it's hilarious the
game the character does not take himself
seriously it almost has like a he almost
feels like Star-Lord with a group of
these Misfit kind of guys and he just
and his plans are always the worst like
his plan he they'd be like yo what are
we doing yeah he's a fool like he's a
straight fool but like I ain't gonna
front like the soundtrack yo gotta be
like yo what what nine inch nail song is
that what is like it it'd be docking I
ain't going for it like the the songs
that they've chosen and then like I said
the bees and the bait it's fire go pick
that up if you if you're on defensive on
it it's in Game Pass go check that out
they did that it is an amazing game it
actually almost got uh what's up I was
gonna say Carl got a few steps oh this
song's kicking yeah who who's that who
who made it oh who is that what yeah
yeah yeah I was like yo what's that I
gotta get there I got to get that album
you know what I'm saying so yeah salute
to them they did that and uh yo you
wanted all these super chats songs yeah
yes I know I know your mess is back
let it play oh I ain't gonna blow it up
he got some wild stuff I I'm copy and
pasting as you speak give me a moment
here and we got the Best Buy kids movie
to build the kids with whatever
what's up Lord Cognito Lord sarvin
addict yo that was good brother look at
the lower part and I just got addicted
you saw that jacket he's like you just
added yeah he was at it today you're not
about that
I think you're too young to be
identified as Lord
take that away from
Bob anyway
Taco member for one year ten dollars to
attack Nintendo switch surpasses the PS4
before its sixth year and has amazing
sales numbers posted for the quarter but
the topic is about the uh about the only
somewhat negative media bias against
Nintendo
we're talking about the Nintendo Direct
what you want man it's gonna be a lot of
love it gotta be a love then we got
Nintendo the yeah Taco I don't know who
this is remember what yeah two thousand
chat I decided to rep the set I'm no
longer Donald Taco thank you the
transformation is absurd we like that we
like you leveled up let's put the crust
in the chat by Cedric H remember for 31
months Lord silver shout out to you sir
yeah
then we got Robert kellett two dollar
Super Chat hog leg
holy oh hole which is well now let's
address this man I'm not about any of
this shortening of names I'm not about
this
bs2 I I don't want to hear no T lose I
don't want to hear that
Hogwarts Legacy The Last of Us yeah
that's what we call it okay yes I don't
want to I'm tired of these these
abbreviations for no reason yeah like
you don't have enough air to say the
whole thing too
oh God
yo 50th is stupid he said attic look
like a gigolo with the coat yo stop it
anyway continue yeah you know it's funny
they they don't they don't like if I if
I don't look like that stereotypical
beard dude they ain't like about that
but I don't look like that they're like
you say right because you know what it
is you got you got the cut normally we
used to see yeah you look like you're
about to expose yourself yeah like you
look like you bought you something
flashing so like like you're just a name
for the Resident Evil for a merchant
I can't I can't anyway move it up yeah
no more of this abbreviations what are
you buying I buy it at a high price
thank you chill no I don't want to hear
that I don't want to hear that no thank
you yeah we got five dollars
78 was good Lord's here to always show
my support to my brothers here to it
here's to a great show hope you all have
a wonderful day you as well brother good
to see you what's love what's love
then we have Lord Metroid the member for
one year 2015 Metroid prime rate
mastered is a dream come true for me for
me as well it is a beautiful thing no
doubt slow salute then we have let's
play with each other's joysticks five
dollar Super Chat so y'all don't enjoy
putting hot white cream in your mouth
that's not my favorite
whoa whoa he wow
wow yeah two extra it's too early for
that bro come on relax this is problem
this is probably them in in the the
what's it recorded the defining Duke
yeah it's probably yeah yeah he'll be on
it yes I'll do some research what's up
go ahead addict okay someone said I got
to do some research and find out that
this that account come around when Carl
joined the funny dude
I don't know the origins
this is a family show though this is a
family show you know what I mean but we
we appreciate your adoring of solve
though we appreciate that continue we
have Hollywood rules five dollars Super
Chat happy ILP Sunday to my NYC and
Virginia cousins smooth was good high
ply Rush is so good ready for the Super
Bowl and Ant-Man next week great pod
guys thank you thank you thank you shout
outs move too you already know we all
caught up yes sir all right all right
let's get to it you know what I'm saying
now that my man's been extremely patient
you know what I'm saying and uh more
Mark is in the building we gotta we
gotta folks which are focused you know
what I'm saying today's video game
system history his journey and his
sketch comedy and stand up and of course
what led him to break in the internet on
Tick Tock and Instagram so uh Lord
Michael let's start from the very
beginning what were some of the first
video game systems you had what kind of
got you into gaming
um so the first system I remember having
back in the day was uh Nintendo 64. uh
oh Jesus we got someone my age for once
shut up
uh so I Nintendo 64 and then I remember
I just played so much NFL Blitz like
let's go
uh constantly and I loved like that
early N64 Blitz because it would like
glitch all the time and I remember like
one time uh like I was playing as the
Packers and Brett Favre for some reason
kind of like a black man and I was like
yeah
NFL Blitz I love when you could like
elbow drop people and all that yes and I
also was super into WCW NWO Revenge
I gotta stop you tell me those wasn't
the best wrestling games of all time
come on come on they're the best like
WWF no mercy I'll never forget I had I
probably was playing that game for like
two three months when I realized you
could throw people backstage and then I
was like and you could like Stone Cold
some people through the pool table like
it was yeah it was oh my God
yes but he revenge and low-key revenge
is my favorite because the jump the jump
from world tour to Revenge was kind of
Bonkers if you really about it Revenge
was the template for everything moving
forward with the WWE games but that
Revenge oh man yeah we had so much fun
with that game okay the intro sequence
to that is so insane yes it is and then
it just like sticks yeah yes it's just
like beanie and they're just like
like rendering these terrible these
terrible polygons
it was so good though it what I liked
about it was such a simplistic system
where it was like strike and remember
the block they put their chests down and
then you had yeah yeah
and the counter yeah and to me where the
real the sheistiness starts right if you
do it like the Royal Rebels or the tag
matches or somebody get eliminated and
the person be outside the ring and he
tried to grab your legs and you you got
whoever's doing that to you got beef
like it's on now if that person costs
you to match like it would be a serious
argument in the house with us we we
would do broke backs we would do
tournaments king would he bought the
real belt and we would do Terminus we
create a pay-per-view and whoever won
that Saturday they get to take the Bell
home so it was bragging right it's crazy
and it was the big WCW like the big fat
like WCW Heavyweight Championship belt
like yeah oh my God and I tell you
something the secret sauce to that game
which I do not understand to this day is
that Spirit meter yes Spirit meter I
don't know what the algorithm is behind
that or whatever but it made those
matches so tense and so much fun you
never knew when you would be able to get
a counter off like sometimes when late
in the match when you both were tired
and it that would make for some amazing
last minute pins yes or like pulling off
a super move last minute I mean there
were moments in that game yeah for sure
for sure I will say lastly we forget
about the box is that it's funny that
you mentioned experiment because like
whoever liked the popular wrestlers were
sometimes it would only take like two
three moves
and that joint is Raging they ready to
do their super and I'm just like oh man
so yeah we used to have something shout
out to your brother your brother known
for abusing that serious spirit being
assisted oh my God we know about you bro
citizens in the chat laughing two two
supers he fitting you when you're out of
here
but anyway continue Marcus so you're
doing the wrestling games on 64. what
else she's doing I know I mean obviously
we all had a double set gold 907 uh
frigate probably my favorite Mission
um I think there was like that was the
one we had to go through and save the
hostages and yeah
yeah the music everything that game all
my all my success so that game shout out
we're composing
salute that's one of your claim to faves
that uh that uh Infamous pause music
I know I know and then uh through there
I went uh I jumped ship I became a
PlayStation boy I had a PS2
and some of my I think my all-time
favorite game from that era is Bully
like rockstars
that game was so I it's it's crazy how
like underrated that game still is
because most of my friends
like who grew up playing games with me
never got around to playing that one and
it's it's an absolute blast man like it
definitely doesn't get enough credit for
what it did yeah they it's still I mean
like all the Rockstar Classics you can
get it on like the PlayStation store and
I went and played through it like a year
and a half ago and it surprisingly still
really holds up like it's still it's
that you know you go back you play those
old games they're still kind of clunky
in some respects but it's still so much
fun so much oh yes you got your PS2
bully classic what else you've been
rocking any other standouts from the PS2
era that you remember uh yeah I had a uh
I really love Spider-Man 2 from that era
I couldn't believe that was back when
every movie had a video yes tell them
yeah what a what a what a wild egg
because it was it was like movies it's
like why why do we have a video game for
like the these films that are terrible
you know what I mean to games with trash
well you could tell it was a literal
buy-in with the license and the game
Association you
um yeah so I had uh yeah like Bully and
uh uh Spider-Man 2 gun was a big one
from that era yeah
yeah I think it was Activision but yeah
it was like that was like the first fun
Cowboy game I remember playing uh the
story mode was crazy you could get this
weapon that was like a bow and arrow
with dynamite attached to it
people all over the map and it was
horribly violent and I was like should I
be doing this
just letting them rip man like salute
blown off some steam just exploding a
whole town what a what a magical time
2005 was oh God Rebecca that was a
unique one but that was one of the early
three I think it was one of the early
360s yeah it was a 360 launch title yeah
yeah
it was and it was it was cross-gen too
it was dead yes yeah so you go there and
then um at that point we just kind of
just staying in the ecosystem and we're
just continuing getting like PS3 with a
PS4 like how did it go what was the next
progression
I gotta I said I went uh PS3 next uh I
wasn't I don't know I like I at this
point am you know how it was when you're
just like no this is this is my system
right oh my we gotta stay with it so I
went PS3 which surprisingly in 2006
Super controversial I feel like PS3 kind
of like crumbled their launch off top
you know like they kind of it was like
not tight I thought it was cool though
because the PS3 you could play PS2 and
PS1 games yes
deal so uh but yeah then from there PS3
uh some standouts to me I think the
first game I remember playing on PS3 and
absolutely loving it was Def Jam icon no
icon yes classic icon that was the last
one that came out right yeah yeah that's
when the games look like all the games
are like fight night yeah we're doing
that engine yes you were talking with uh
like Rhythm games earlier like Def Jam
icon was a rhythm because you could like
each rapper could control the music and
whatever
they're Spirit meters like if you had
like TI if you're fighting as TI and you
had what you know playing if your song
was playing you had like a bonus and
like strength and stuff environmental
disasters would like kick on it was so
fun yes it's kind of crazy that no one's
tried to recreate that again I know I
know no it'd be so fun these days yeah
the song in my opinion was Paul Wall
sitting sideways because it just
happened and it was like you were the
explosions were always happening
don't get me wrong I thought that was
like a petition or something for Def Jam
something to come back am I bugging yeah
yeah you're interested to get so many
retweets or likes and they they I think
they trolling us because they haven't
done nothing since then yeah I feel like
there's got to be like people that they
would put as actual Fighters that's not
that they don't think that or giving
them issue that they know that they
can't bring back without those prey
people you know what I'm saying like
maybe some licensing issues
I'm pretty sure with this day and age
and this day and age of hip-hop and the
lack of because remember you know sales
was everything they need more Revenue
sources it'll be a lot easier to get
today's musicians
fdm type game today's musicians I think
I'm referring to more of the old ones
and I think they're probably having more
issues with them because they probably
want more money than the modern ones do
yeah it could be I mean who knows how
the metrics work out or not part but
it's a shame like I said I feel I agree
with you addict like it's a to me that's
a it's an easy win you know what I'm
saying if they brought those back
because to me if it was just a matter of
bringing it back they know they can make
money off of that it just it feels like
how would you guys be if they brought
like they made a new one and then have
none of the old the old Garden but then
again you got it okay like a vast
majority of the morning like no I get
that I get them that gets expensive that
many people they do get expensive what I
was thinking is they just go clean slate
let's go for the Young Generation you
know what I'm saying little little baby
picture dude if they can't get the old
guard it should be a young versus The
Old Guard like like some kind of torta
between the young the old people and the
the young man I'll be fine I'll be
listen I'll be back with it so you got
that so we stick PS3 rocking rocking
that joint and then um any other stand
I'm from the PS3 generation you remember
that she was really standing taller uh
yeah I was super into the skate games uh
I grew up skateboarding and so skate was
like such a big breath of fresh air uh
and now I know they're coming back and
it's free to play and it's like but we
actually know the the lead we know the
leaders
he's been on the show yeah that's the
guy yeah that's so sick yeah that guy
seems like such a good time he's always
just like every time I've seen that guy
he's always like I can't believe I get
to make this game either
shout out to Mr McCullough man that's
the legendary Lord dead no doubt so you
know the skate and all that cool cool
anything else from there for the PS3 uh
really fun I mean I don't know if you
guys ever played this one but WWE
All-Stars I feel like that's a slip-on
game from that era that game was so fun
just like flying around and it was like
if you combine NFL Blitz and you know
we're talking about earlier where uh it
was just this because I hadn't played a
wrestling game in so long and it just
somehow became this one beautiful
mishmash of like what a wrestling game
could be with all the over the top and I
think they tried to remake like a kind
of WWE All-Stars recently and I was like
you know and I was like this is not as
fun
now you're right it was over the top it
was very over the tower remember all
stars I did I remember getting into that
yeah it did take itself seriously a lot
of silliness a lot of fun you know what
I'm saying so we got that and then now
at this point we're going PS4 we're just
going straight through it and I'm just
gonna ask the Xbox Community gonna be
bad it could be like he didn't get a 360
he didn't he he didn't get it any Xbox
so so what was that about
uh I don't know I just like am I I was a
young child that's not gonna be an
excuse in the chat
for Christmas and then I just grew up
playing that and then got up PS3 I don't
personally like have any problems with
Xbox I really like one of my favorite
games from uh that PS2 era was Jade
Empire which was an Xbox
um
yeah I just always was a PlayStation kid
I mean my parents are divorced and at my
dad's house my brothers had an Xbox so I
kind of got to like every every like
Christmas break summer break I was like
kind of I was Behind Enemy Lines
that's what's up that's what's up I'm
assuming PS4 give me some standouts I
know we talked earlier we talked we
could finish PS3 because we talked
earlier about last of us and we was
talking about in the pre-show about the
show and everything so I'm assuming you
had the PS3s version last of us and then
I'm assuming you go into PS4 so tell us
about that
yeah PS3 Last of Us was a big one for me
uh on there also I mean it's it's like
the biggest game ever but GTA 5 was like
it's nuts to me that that was I still
think that that was a PS3 game when it
first came out
um I just think a funny GTA 5 story I
was uh in college at the time that came
out and I remember at the time I lived
with two dudes that were in a fraternity
and they were having like this big
pregame to like go out to the bars and
stuff and I had just gotten GTA 5 and I
was over there playing it and so there's
there's like a bunch of sorority girls
in the kitchen like mixing it up with
all these dudes from their frat and one
of them is like yo here's GJ smart and
they just immediately migrated like
ditched all of the all of the girls
playing GTA 5.
bro
GTO GTA 5 was huge
YouTube
before trust me that was a huge ego
attack to them oh yeah they was like
what did
they you are a beautiful woman but I can
literally hijack a fighter jet and crash
it into a golf course yeah I gotta go I
gotta go yeah I gotta go baby I gotta go
absolute man yeah Classics then
obviously PS4 any of the um so would you
would you rocking
the god of war and all that stuff as
well and you know the original the ogs
yeah I played I played uh I played the
first I think two God of Wars like way
back in the day I don't I I tried to
play God of War 3 I just kind of never
really finished it
um but then when PS4 came around I did
play the original god of war and I was
kind of like I was a late adopter to it
because I was like I don't know like
it's different
it's like not Greece anymore
when I finally did play it I was like
dude this is so sick I really loved it's
just so much fun to just throw the ax
and make it come back to you
um yeah I loved it uh Spider-Man
obviously
uh Red Dead Redemption 2 what I'm
actually solve as a logo now you may saw
you see what's all the besties now
that game was just so insane I was a big
fan of Red Dead Redemption Undead
Nightmare on the PS3 uh which was like
the DLC the zombie one and I thought
that was so cool so it was really cool
to see in rdr2 them incorporate some
like Supernatural elements and stuff
it's just the most fun I would play that
it took me so I like took so long to
finish that game because I would load it
up and just spend hours just like just
messing around yeah
like even though the mechanic didn't
really matter I would like hunt to be
like I brought you a deer like to the
pan the guy's like thanks and he's like
starts trapping up it's just like all
those little details in that game that
make it so good
yeah man not a great great game of
History man lovely to hear it brother
this is this is dope all those games
Classics Man actually class it up and
it's cool that you still kind of stand
with it you know while you doing your
your career and all that so I was going
to ask you to transition just a little
bit was like now obviously comedy get
started your journey you know what I
mean so like what how did that start
like was it what are the things that
naturally it came to you was one of the
funniest Kids on the Block kind of
situation or was like something that you
grew appreciation for and then which
came first like the sketch or the stand
like how did that how did that go yeah
so it kind of Comedy was something that
I always really loved I remember being
like a kid and watching comedy central
presents back in the day like I remember
seeing like the old like I remember
seeing Kevin Hart's Comedy Central
presents when he had like the white cap
on like this is like pre-soul playing
this was like wet before yeah it's Kevin
Hart's breakout film Soul Plane
yes yes yeah and so I always loved stand
up and all that and uh when I first got
to uh when I was in high school I would
always be like doing skits at Pep
rallies and stuff like
and when I got to college
um I was involved at the radio station
at Florida State and the radio station
there is kind of weird because like they
they didn't really want you to like be
funny like it
every DJ there they sound like they are
uh like leaving a voicemail at a library
they're like okay we just heard um
I meant someone who invited me to
audition for a sketch comedy group on
campus and I got in and then that was
like game over then I was like I found
this I'm not doing
um so I was doing sketch comedy at first
and then I started doing stand-up over
the summer in college like a few months
later and then it was pretty much like
all right cool like once I graduate I'm
moving to LA and I'm doing this
full-time so
I've been doing comedy since 2014 so
going on nine years now
and one of the biggest things that
happened uh was when the pandemic hit
March 2020 and the lockdown came I'm out
in L.A like we were you know locking
that locking it up and not really doing
too much so I couldn't go do stand up I
couldn't go do sketch comedy so I kind
of had to just learn how to like shoot
and edit videos on my own if I wanted
them
so having that constraint
um really was something that helped push
me to like learn how to edit videos and
do all this and then that was about
three years history so nah brother
that's fired I love The Inspirations I
love you what you talked about I got it
it's funny you say that with the whole
pandemic now because to me I think we
got let's talk about one of your magic
moments where I think you came across my
radar and a lot of the gaming
communities radar and like bro you broke
the internet with the N64 the golden uh
pause music skit like tell us about that
and then like did you won did you know
it was a banger when you made it that's
number one and then two like what's up
with those try to steal your swag and
try to act like they was the first like
let's get into the concert
like Bob let's just for the record set
it set the record straight big time back
like you are the OG originator of the
golden out pause music bop the whole
thing so let's break that origin the
whole thing so it'll be I mean like I
said earlier gold9007 I always loved uh
listening to music and Hip-hop music and
even I remember even as like a kid
loving that pause music so much uh I
actually back when I was like making
comedy wraps in college in like 2013 I
turn up Tuesdays where every Tuesday I
would drop a sound a song on my like
SoundCloud and I had like a really old
song about that like had a beat sampled
from that that was like about me rapping
about being James Bond and stuff
um well it turned up Tuesday I love that
it's turned up too I'm sorry I'm dying
turn up Tuesday son I'm feeling that
continue
you and the song 2013 rapping you know
about being James Bond and stuff and
then I always it was an idea that I'd
always had I was like I remember trying
to do it as a stand-up bit but like
obviously like no one was like what are
you talking about
um and the funny part about that video
was I actually had filmed it about a
month or two before
and something with the maybe I was just
having like an off day or something but
I was like I went back and watched it
and I was like I don't really like this
I'm gonna like put this on the shelf for
now and then I'll come back and about a
month and a half later I came back to it
I was like oh let's knock that out real
quick good and it's one of those videos
that truly I was like oh this is
probably gonna be like super Niche like
I'll throw it up we'll see whatever can
happen and yes I basically reawaken the
collective conscience of like three
generations for people because I put
that up and I remember like I put it up
like I uploaded at like 5 p.m a friend
of mine uh there had a show at the
Hollywood improv so I went down there
just to like hang out with everyone and
just and support and then when I came
out I remember checking my phone and it
had gone to like like 200 000 and I was
like
I was in and then I woke up the next day
and it was like millions and then if
people were like tagging and posting it
everywhere and I was just like what is
happening it's kind of crazy to see a
viral video on Tick Tock because you
don't refresh it and it'll go up like 30
40 000 views like it's like you're
literally just pressing your thumb down
and you're seeing Mass amounts of views
go on this video
it was super crazy because it was just
like this video idea that I had had for
a while this thing that I'd been
championing for so long and then just
like to see it finally explode was wild
and then not too long after that uh
which one of the things I'm most proud
of was that video got reposted on
Worldstar
I made Worldstar without getting uh beat
up you ain't get robbed
I made I did a world star on my terms
um so yeah it was it was nuts man and
then like a few days later seeing all
the people like start to do all the
copycats and stuff I just kind of took
that as like a super duper compliment
because I was like wow really this thing
I made you guys think is cool enough
that you want to like yeah it was bite
it was biting the stat it's biting the
swag you know what I'm saying I'll put
it up in the chat yo go go subscribe to
The Tick Tock man he killed that that's
what I first came across it I was just
dying it was just like you for those who
don't know like he's playing the role of
someone who's like the the the
conceptual stage we're looking for you
know some a really cool pause music for
a game you're the producer you're
playing both characters and he's like
what about this oh and then the faces is
wow for the the Bop is is crazy the
whole thing go check that out put it up
in the chat it definitely hits different
so salute that that's what really took
it off and obviously you got a ton other
stuff that's what I found out you did
videos the the producer tag stuff is
hilarious a lot of producer tag stuff
that's really funny and then obviously
was to what you're going on now so what
I was going to ask you too was like now
that you've done sketch and stand up
what do you prefer do you prefer the
traditional stand-up style you know
comedy or you know what are you doing
kind of now when you kind of adjusted
during the pandemic
uh I I love I love stand up it's so fun
but I think I do prefer like video
sketch uh better just because I love
that it'll like I I really thrive in
that environment of being able to
control like the cuts and like the zooms
and a lot of like text on my videos and
stuff because I think that's so much fun
um but stand up will always have a place
in my heart because at the end of the
day there's really nothing like being
able to go on stage and just like have a
and then I would assume I'm not in that
field but I would assume you know the
tick tock and you know the short content
and the videos that's easier to monetize
as well yeah exactly yeah
it's I'm not really at a point where
it's like
I'm making like a ton of money off of it
yeah nice little like you know boost and
monetizing and getting like brand deals
and all those other stuff which is so
funny because I just did that that video
took that goal in that video took me
maybe like 45 minutes to shoot in
another like 30 minutes to edit and it
was like the best 75 investment of my
entire career but I love stand-up though
because I like doing live shows and like
I have plans to go do shows in other
cities like last September I did a show
in New York
sold it out it was fun
I did a show in Brooklyn and it's it's
an absolute blast so just ideally I
would like to get to a point where I can
combine like Live sketch with like video
assistance and stand up and music and
kind of become like one-man show very
much like a like a Bo Burnham or
something yeah no I got you man and I
think that's dope that you're able to
kind of marry both of that because at
least what I saw coming up because I'm
older so you know I'm from the you know
traditional to the priors The Murphys
The Rocks and all of that but like what
I was noticing is like the younger
generation that I would I want to say
like the social media style comedians I
was noticed it as like a little little
beef like where the stand-up dudes don't
really respect that you know what I'm
saying like what we doing is the real
thing so it's interesting that you're
kind of doing both and do you see that
do you see like you know the OG's ain't
feeling this social media comedy so to
speak that's that's a great question
um there was like this weird taboo like
pre-pandemic with stand up that like no
one no one posted stand-up Clips
absolutely no one posted stand-up clips
and it was kind of like this hack thing
to do
um and then I think once people started
posting stand-up clips and having
incredible success with it like uh
nimesh Patel is a comedian who started
posting his stand-up clips and just
exploded and like this you know Nanda
and just like people that got really
prolific and were putting that work in I
think people saw that
um and my response to that would be like
we live in a world where the internet
and social media has really just allowed
you to take the reins on stuff
um like I want to shout out my friend
Niles abstin he's a really good comedian
absolutely uh and he started like just
filming specials like I run a stand-up
show out of my house in LA and I have
for five years
and he filmed a whole special in my
house three years ago and now he's done
two more specials and he writes on Dave
for FL it's like it's kind of like this
thing where it's it's waiting for you to
go get it if you just want to get it but
I think you know people always kind of
like hate on the the first person to do
something yeah or but uh I mean I do see
that but I feel like in LA it's a very
young comedy scene it's a very like
supportive comedy scene a lot of us are
on the same page with that I feel like
maybe in like other cities it might be a
little bit of like well you know I'm
honest you gotta keep it at pure you're
not keeping it true like we
clout though you have no Cloud so that's
a talk about you know what I mean it's
true that's true you listen you got it
you got to reach all the demographics
and what I like is that you can do both
right you you could you're not locked in
on one particular style side of the game
so salute to you on that the other thing
I want to get in before we move on was
um gotta respect you know I'm saying
that you're in corporation of like the
hip-hop and the boss into the cop car
but obviously you know the laws a lot of
us come from hip-hop so like what
inspired that passion to keep that going
then tell us about the new Drake you got
going the bet the BET by nine r b
situation what's going on with that
so I was just always like I said I've
always loved hip-hop I remember growing
up always wanted to listen to like the
hip-hop station shouts out 93 BLX
Pensacola Mobile Alabama
Roy Jones home Royal Jones Homer Emma
Smith you know what I'm saying Brooks
and me I'm up I'm gonna be on the Mount
Rushmore let's go big time Market let's
go yeah I've always I've always been
into that I've always loved like hip-hop
and all that stuff like uh like I was on
I was on my step team in high school if
that paints oh
and like my like my like eight ladies
and we rock it halftime every basketball
game
um and just to be honest with you I've
always had such an appreciation for like
black culture and what it's the impact
it's had on my life and so I've always
tried to incorporate that in a very
respectful way into my art
um and I love you know hip-hop and
obviously uh for a while there was that
kid from your hometown that was trying
to be a rapper and then once I finally
embraced like being funny and like
because that's the stuff people
responded to I started finding a groove
on it
and so yeah I've always but like I said
like earlier I mentioned that uh my
first foray into comedy was making like
little YouTube raps in high school and I
was like really silly stuff like
midnight snack about how like me we're
like creeping down trying to like not
get caught by her parents eating you
know
stuff like that so it was a thing that
kind of went dormant for a while and
then when the pandemic uh hit and I
started making videos one of the First
videos I put up was this uh little like
Instagram rap song called late 20s and
it's just about me being in my late 20s
and it just it was really silly but
people liked it so I kept doing some and
have two friends of mine that are very
good their names are Tommy and Aaron
they're a rap group called run the fools
they're on all streaming platforms look
them up they just dropped a song called
insecurities that is so good okay
I paired up with them and they kind of
got me back into it so now uh I recorded
this song called bed by nine which you
know
one and like nothing hits like a good
night's sleep so I got this song that's
about how like you know my lady is like
trying to get a little nasty with me and
I'm like look baby girl like
you know what you gotta see it though
it's a blast it's uh it's on all
streaming platforms bed by nine uh by
Big Time macca and I'm crowdfunding we
we just hit our 80 threshold
we so far we've raised over 12 000 for
it
um but yeah we're gonna shoot a music
video for it at the end of the month and
it's gonna be so good
yeah I'm gonna put the link in the
description go check that out man that
joint is funny it's hilarious good
I have a question how
how much of a tour has Tick Tock been
for you
uh it's been pretty good Tick Tock is
weird because the algorithm they keep
like changing it and I feel like on Tick
Tock you can kind of get pigeonholed and
stuff
um because I do a lot of stuff I do like
a lot of absurd comedy I do a lot of
like character based comedy but I also
do like dance comedy and I feel like
because the golden Knight video blew up
it kind of like put me into like that
dance category so anytime I post
something that's not like remotely like
dancing
but that being said I mean I I I I love
it I think it's it's a huge huge tool
because without it I wouldn't have had
that golden eye video pop off and that
goal in that video kind of did break the
seal shout out to be Lou he said run the
fools is hilarious yeah he definitely
went with the fools I think that they
Tick Tock needs to embrace what they do
differently and stop trying to compete
with other people no I feel you I feel
you and then um the thing I was gonna
say when you talk about the videos like
I caught a couple of old instruments bro
please be my agent sir
you was Walling on that and there's a
no-yo and he got another one where he
like it's called foreign like I got the
four Whip and he says Hyundai Sonata or
whatever it was and he acted like it's
the hottest joint you you don't even
know like like the way he acts and the
way his shot is how it's really well
done
yeah it's a it's the you know it's the
to me you know it's the Weird Al energy
like the word out yeah everywhere it's
like you know you just take you just
take subjects that it's like anybody
else who just it's a passerby like
whatever one-off comment or something
like that and you take that and you turn
it into something and it's like not
everybody's able to do that and find the
comedy in little it like it just kind of
mundane things that we do all the time
and you just do find the comedy in that
as soon as I heard this stuff I'm like
oh yeah this is this is this is odd it's
like the modern day of that but the
Twitter version of like wear it out I
was like yeah that this is amazing stuff
yeah it kind of reminds me of uh smooth
making a video about blocking people on
Twitter yeah like what would be coming
in I get bad as well he need to do more
that because smooth is from that pocket
it's more be having balls y'all need to
lick you know what I'm saying because at
the end of the day like that's that type
of stuff that I don't see a lot of
people doing it's original you flip it
and then the um the other thing I was
gonna say is he just made a a Game Pass
Anthem smooth dude
you had a what is it the forza yeah
the hell gears enforce it yeah no that I
gotta um check out uh Big Mac and stuff
because that's um the type of stuff like
I enjoy like that that comes up that
people like is it and the thing is a lot
of times it's just beyond like the
comedy in it is actually good yeah not
it is it is like he'd be having a choice
you know like okay okay I was gonna say
the probably the the most memorable
thing I've seen does was the uh the
switch fights those three switch ones so
those are hilarious The Joint that he do
but I could do that y'all got a peep I
like what he does anything with produce
attacks like he got one solved with like
the arm like it's a religious joke like
come on oh damn Jesus getting let him
get a hold of this like are they
dropping the producer like busted on the
beat you know like when he do the
producer tags on anything I'll be dying
bro where you started that to put put me
on today what is that whole thing
started with the produced I mean like I
said like uh I remember I went to
college in Atlanta my freshman year uh
and this is like 2010 2011 so this is
like right when trap sound was blowing
up and that was right when I kind of
started noticing well obviously like you
know we had like gangster Grizzly meals
and like all those things from like the
Limelight it takes the grills
so funny I used to have like an old
stand-up joke about how like producer
tags and how it's like at the time I was
working in restaurants and I was like
could you imagine if I was bartending
and I poured someone a beer and I was
like
[Laughter]
I think producer tags are so funny
because it's truly like the whole song
could be absolutely banging but the
producer just like one beautiful window
to be like I did it yeah that's his
shame that's the time to shine he gonna
let you know that's his beat on this
like Michael Mike Will made it Mike Will
made it
so good like a good produce deck hit so
obviously putting them on everything
like the country music one oh
no Classics bro you got them with this
one bro and then just uh the the one
you're talking about the church music
one is it's damn Jesus where'd you find
this
that's my joint right there so yo you
killed that you killed that y'all put
the links to the channel man go support
my man he's out here killing it and the
last thing I did want to say I want to
stand up Tim I want to give you a props
it added you gotta watch this joint he
got a joint with like hip-hop and it's
like things as a white guy he can't say
or like that he appreciates about him
but he finds interesting and I thought
that was hilarious man some salute
support and uh just telling people what
else you got going on man
oh man I mean I'm uh like I said I'll be
trying to I'm doing shows in other
cities later in the year but I think the
big thing is just my music video
um we're crowdfunding for it if you if
you want to support uh I'll definitely
shoot the Lincoln and
uh I'll just uh I'll throw it to you
guys in the chat with you he already put
it in the chat hold down put the I put
the whole link so they can go catch the
socials yeah I got that follow me on
Instagram uh Tick Tock at Big Time Maca
uh Twitter it's the same I think there's
underscores big underscore time
underscore macca because someone already
who I was like who is this other big
time member what are you hitting out
here Friday now
but uh yeah I got that and then just
when the music video comes out um I'll
definitely shoot at you guys as well I
can't wait hey yo bro when you pull up
and why let me know when you're doing a
live show we're going the Lord's will
come through you know yeah for your
comedy bro I come from that era I would
go to the little comedy sellers you know
what I mean you get the show and you
just hang out you chill have a good time
man cool advice
yeah oh we're gonna bring you at it
don't be ripping or one of those but I I
feel like I stand out enough that I'll
be too much of a Target oh yeah you
definitely gonna be a talk it's no no
question like me and my man if you go in
the front row for the most part you
gonna get it you're gonna get it we from
there
middle down so before we all wrap up I
wanted to ask like questions we asked
all the guests in the realm I need Laura
Marcus top five video games or
franchises of all time cool oh man
that's tough all right
um
let me think no particular order no
particular order
let me see all right well I'm gonna
start I think I will say I think my
favorite game of all time uh is Bully oh
first just because of that obviously
that's I need to I'm gonna make it I'm
gonna write that down let me make a tick
tock about that one because
that one is so crazy man the the
soundtrack for it is crazy
um yes I would say uh my top five are
probably gonna be bullied
Last of Us Part One no doubt I Champion
wait which Champion Fight Night Champion
oh yeah classics
um I would say uh skate two
uh NBA Street volume two oh very
ridiculous little Sports little okay
salute so highly recommend you do video
game tick tocks I'm just saying I'm a
Gaming Community we come we support bro
we support I'm just saying it might
slowly get you out of that that dancing
little algorithm that you went to
but don't stop the dance moves though
don't stop the Dead foreign
console of all time and why uh okay I
will say uh favorite console PlayStation
2. I was actually thinking about this
the other day it's it was like this
beautiful time where video games weren't
as big of a of a market yet that like
they were just making such weird off the
wall like Katamari damachi was like you
know what I mean like little games like
that like mosquito just like these
random weird like what if you could do
this and they would just make the game
uh outside of the Nostalgia like NHL
hits was huge now all these old
absolutely banging games that people
were able to make because you know they
didn't have this huge development
process they have now uh and so it was
like it was like the perfect little
window I feel like by the time you got
to the PS3 360 like Wii era stuff had
kind of started to like funnel I mean
now it's like no you're right yes no
you're absolutely right and I think
that's a that's a valid point because
you see I think to your to your point I
felt like you got more diverse genres
and then people were taking more
creative risks whereas as games got more
expensive like you said they didn't
start to funnel you got it's kind of get
more of the same games where I think you
might like is more of the Indie scene
too because the Indie currently right
now I think they're the ones that's kind
of pushing the boundaries trying
different things from that era that
you're talking about and I think you you
might appreciate that we have a big time
Market in the realm absolute pleasure
for you to pull up thank you for taking
the time you know what I'm saying and
again telephon people where they can
find you where they can support you what
we got going on before we get about it
yeah hit me on Tick Tock Instagram at
Big Time Maca uh I have a link tree it
usually has links to my shows my other
channels uh whatever
um hit me up I usually always I will
respond to DMS and like chat about stuff
if you want uh thanks for having me
smooth that was you on the intro thing
right the rap song that was so good
that was not cool that's cool we got it
we got to give Dallas balls his day but
salute this must move dude so we've got
bars though we've got balls
balls level one smooth anthems and
you'll find smooth stuff yeah look up
kids moves and some you'll definitely
definitely find kiss moves on that one
and then uh yeah man appreciate you
brother again much respect Big Time
mocking and building so if you want to
say the outros and attic with outro for
big time I can play goodbye no my God
like I said man like I said everything
that you do and and it's people don't
realize how tough it is like to do stand
up and just to do comedy comedy in
general like it's such a subjective
thing that for you to find a lane that
everybody finds like amusing and funny
it's a difficult thing you know
oftentimes you see people that are
comedians like really not you know
that's that kind of their way to sort of
let the let the hurt out you know what I
mean and for somebody to genuinely enjoy
it like I said I see it in everything
that you do and I it I just got Weird Al
Vibes and just taking these things that
people like everybody notices everybody
sees but nobody is going to say hey
let's make a whole song about this thing
and I I love that I love that so keep
doing what you do man no doubt Lord
adding any words for the big time not
going the way out yeah I appreciate you
coming on uh one thing I appreciate is
you showing a cog of this Tick Tock that
I've been preaching for so long because
I'm the old I'm the old head of the cast
so you'd be like Carl I'm telling you
he's looking at that as like some some
like Teenage dance app and you know they
the way they promoted Tick Tock when it
first came out didn't make things any
easier uh but you know I like I like
that Cog brought someone off from Tick
Tock this is someone put this in the
record the book out there somewhere
listen I had to learn my lesson shot at
the attic put me on game you know what
I'm saying and then also and then
obviously Market came across my line I'm
like all right I'm understanding what
the youth is doing
on the checkout
and I appreciate the stuff you do
um it's inspiring
um and it's just good to see uh people
content creators uh come up in a way you
did it where it's like
that out of the blue catching lightning
in the bottle and then coming off and
then inspiring other people to do uh
certain things and try to come off with
the for the same come up so it's a good
look um I like the stuff that you do and
um okay you got a new fan in me so no
doubt no well you guys got you guys all
got a new fan in me I had so much is
awesome like I'm definitely gonna tune
in I might be in the chat hating
I need you I need you to cover their
heat and I need you to start your your
foolishness
and shout out to someone that came on
that's around my age see you we had to
do that
we I'm getting age shape that's cool
though it's cool it's a little big town
you guys h a me 24 7. of course of
course it's your time baby it's your
time to shout it's a little big town
bucket to build a Pensacola stand up you
already know thank you brother thank you
for your time enjoy your day you know we
gonna link up again let me know when you
pull up in New York we coming through
foreign
[Music]
I was thinking what um he was sitting
and I was like I don't know if he wants
to stick around for these topics no no
we get now he got stuff he had to do
because I I want I won't mock it like
here we go we go
we we do this we do this that's a little
marketing building
hi Lords hi chat everyone please hit the
like button thank you sir listen to this
tomorrow for my work day keep up the
great work thank you bro appreciate it
down no doubt and let's put the crest in
the chat for Lord bronze Lord roughness
let's put the crest in the chat no damn
that is it we are caught up we all
caught up no doubt No Doubt we gonna get
it before we get to the top let's get
this poll from last week on last week's
poll results and in the people have
spoken with the recent impressive sales
of God of War Ragnarok which upcoming
PlayStation title do you think has the
best shot of beating Ragnarok numbers
the winner of our four-way ILP poll and
an absolute Landslide 82 of the vote
Marvel Spider-Man 2 group that's the
winning thing that's going to do it for
the PlayStation and to throw Ragnarok
coming in at second place seven percent
of the vote was Final Fantasy rebirth
that was second I was surprised by that
third place but five percent of the vote
Marvel's Wolverine which I thought would
be higher and in last place with uh
close four percent to that was um I
don't care naughty dog has entered the
chat group so people feel whatever the
naughty dog might do might get into it
those are the messy Lords doing what
they do
um Lord addict uh you're very high on uh
Spider-Man's potential success of what
it could do do you agree think the wrong
got it right
um
yeah they got it right
[Music]
you already know so we're gonna get into
that and then some couple more Super
chats rolled in and then I got some
patreon questions real quick cool we got
David Ramos two dollars for chat showing
support thanks folks enjoy the Super
Bowl no doubt thank you brother
appreciate that thank you
and we got Spartan go 17 two pounds
Super Chat did attic just say get these
dinosaurs out of here not yet but say
stick around I might say that in the
future I don't know
all caught up it did well we got some
loins of patreon and we got to take care
of
um stop start with a dip down games and
animate a homie stranded on an island
this is for everybody here now that's
the question you're stranded on the
island you have access to one gigabyte
of Internet due to reasons you can bring
One console in three games what's going
in your bag and then here's the
stipulation Game Pass don't work out
there
yes
you know you know he had to get fast
slander right quick to try to check it
so again you're on the island you got a
gigabyte internet you can bring one
console
three games who go first what you doing
well
um what you doing
I'm going with fortnite
any modern calling so far at night
um
I want to say like a giant rpk can the
game come out soon or is it just like as
of right now yeah I'd probably take STAR
Phil so you want something like super It
Grow small like super gross and you can
continue okay probably fall guys when I
get bored in fortnite so
that's a good one kid's gonna pick some
crazy stuff I can almost guarantee
okay okay who will take a stab at it one
console three games only gigabyte
internet can't do it crazy
what's up you up what you doing oh man
which first of all which kind of so I
want to know which console you're taking
why you got console I think I'm taking a
PC with me
that's a cop out that wasn't part of the
deal
taking
MVP Baseball 2005. Classic
and I'm taking I'm probably taking
Starfield
so dip down said there was no PC so so
you had to oh dip down yeah he made the
rules sorry no PC sir you have to be
console
damn there's no place for mvpc there's a
loopholes yeah you see the live holes
it's fine so okay XBox Red Dead 2 same
thing Red Dead Two
um Starfield
and I guess in the whatever the latest
MVP baseball is
fine okay okay
you want me to jump in here
this is fairly easy it's an Xbox and
it's Halo gear is important
so on brand so on red so Halo gives it
for that which all right but let me let
me let's let's make a heart which halo
which gives which force and keep in mind
you don't you you have a gigabyte of
Internet you can't play these games
online like like you'd be thinking that
that's that's fine yeah
man thank you sauce nice Master Chief
Collection uh
here's a war
two
oh nice nice
or it's uh
Horizon
2.
no that'll be three wow I like three but
two had like a two made me fall in love
with Forza brand okay like to the point
like I never played at the time I didn't
play Forza Horizon one and I was just
used to like the standard forces I was
like all right cool but when Forza
Horizon 2 came out everything from the
soundtrack yeah to the open world at
that time Forza Horizon 2 I think
introduced me to Chromeo yeah
yeah two two got two got me into in two
ports as well yeah yeah oh those are
good yeah I got it see damn he took I
was going to cheat also solving to try
to do the PCS oh so that's how so yeah
it's definitely Xbox it's definitely X
but because of the the back
compatibility aspect um
the one giga internet though you killing
my destiny bro like come on like yeah
whatever you know what gigabyte isn't
that bad that's tough for them
he thought about this yeah I'm gonna say
I'm gonna say
Starfield because of what it represents
be a Starfield because of what it
represents you know in space I need one
of those long Skyrim like you know type
experiences surprised I'm gonna have a
I'm gonna have a tekking game I need a
fighting game I need a techie and I
probably if it's if it's future then I'm
gonna go Tekken eight what I mean stop
cheating Kong oh cause you're talking
about PC oh so I got that
and then I need a strategy game the
question is are my heart would say
probably like my ex-con turn base but I
actually would go with dbo I would go
with demio
only for the Dungeons and the
Cooperative joint and stuff like that so
that's probably what I did I got my
strategy I got my fighting I got my RPG
and then I got the console with it by
yourself playing demon I could play dbm
by myself
I could because they have Skirmish mode
and you control all the heroes and then
they got the bosses and stuff I I love
dbo so that's probably you know big city
pushing [__] Puck probably pushing power
on the island yo you stupid
no doubt now what I was gonna say dip
down before we move into the next
question is I was gonna say the steam
debt qualify
because steam deck lets me have every
everything pretty much might I want to
do but we'll see we'll see but anyway
that's what I got and then we get the uh
next question uh it was from Asus uh532
okay uh do you uh do you think Xbox will
have hellblade to release this fall or
Surprises with Contraband and save
hellblade for spring 2024. I want kids
to move first on this I'm curious where
he at with this blade situation
all right repeat that question okay do
you think Xbox will have hellblade 2
release this fall or surprise us with
Contraband and save hellblade for spring
2024.
no I think I think Hellboy this far I
think it's benefits than most if they do
hellblade this fall
um as like
the the big game
um that big fall game because even I
think you already got a third-party game
in um
uh my God stalker stalker two right and
to pair that uh to close out the year
what hell blade uh two and it's like you
know what we think is going to be will
be Monumental where
um nothing Contraband is like a healthy
enough game where they can kick off q1
you know of next year I think it's uh
you want to put more so
you'll get more I don't think Contraband
is going to be like the like a big
holiday hit it might be it might be like
that for example remember how when they
took got back for blood into Game Pass
day one it was supposed to be a big deal
but it wasn't I got quite a big deal I
got shot it was and I think um
I think Contraband is going to be
something like that because I think
Contraband is good it's like sort of a
genre that isn't really truly Mass
Appeal it's like either like a game like
that or you or you don't and I think
that a safe real safe release for that
isn't a holiday where your bundle with
like Call of Duty and whatever EA is
going to be doing or whatever right I
think you know survive uh getting out of
the holiday season and going into that
because who knows the quarter one of
next year may be dry right and that and
then that game could get more eyes than
they probably expected releasing in like
a February March the 24th so I got
hellblade in the fall because I think L
blade is overdue being that it was
revealed in 2019. that's a massive gear
for Xbox so they can pull off hellblade
and Starfield at the same year that
would be insane
um yeah let me I'll jump in um XBox will
have hell play two released this fall I
think I am coming around on the
hellblade train I think I'm coming
around
um
it's been a while like the caseable said
that we've seen it
um they've already shown it twice you
know they showed it with the reveal of
the series X they showed it again
Gameplay trailer you know what I'm
saying maybe two years after that I
think my gut tells me the mindset is if
we see Harold blade again it's with a
release date so if we see Harold blade
again this year let's say at E3 so to
speak right that would it would it would
be a great fall lineup I mean it seems
like it's the year would line up for it
you know so we'll see and I think you
know grub gave you a little confidence
you know said that he he expect baby you
know that it could be there so yeah I
think I'm smooth too or on Contraband
not saying that
Contraband you know wouldn't be big but
I think it's more of an additive piece
as opposed to the you know let's I get I
don't know the full scope of the game
but that's how my gut is right now but
I'm curious you know addict where you at
with it like with this question Hellboy
2 released this fall surprise or
surprise us with Contraband save
hellblade for 20 to sprint in 2024.
I want it the other way around you gave
us Contraband 2024 give us hope late
this year the only way I want it that
way is if hell blade is simply not ready
and Contraband is uh to me you're not
replacing Contraband I mean hell played
with Contraband it's not happening and
uh you're gonna upset people because you
have all these games that you've
announced and none of them are out none
of them we have any solid release dates
I mean we still don't even know when
Starfield and Ford's is coming out at
this time so it's just like nah you know
um
contraband's gonna be a fun game and I
think it could potentially do a lot but
it's never going to replace something
like a hellblade okay so I've close it
out where you got hell bleeding yeah
okay I agree I agree I mean I think
we don't know anything about Contraband
we haven't seen it even once
um and I just think when you look at the
games coming out you need something to
kind of if if you can make comparisons
you need something to to if you're going
to release anything something that's
going to compare to Spider-Man right
so and that would be hellblade I think
Contraband is supposed to be sort of
this multiplayer thing and you know
you're going to be colliding up against
Call of Duty
new seasons of of fortnite War Zone you
know everybody wants to drop their their
hot new uh season you a
multiplayercentric thing brand new
um you want to give it a chance to
breathe and to shine and even though you
know the entire year now is packed full
of for the games I think it still would
be in that game's best interest to come
out in the first quarter as opposed to
you know the fourth quarter of the Year
going up against big boys so if they
manage
have they managed to get start filled
out before June or whatever
um yeah if the hell place ready to go
hellbling because yeah I'm sorry didn't
know because it just it is that thing
where what we've seen of hellblade to
step up from the original hellblade is
significant it has that energy
um and it could surprise against
Spider-Man I'm very excited for
Spider-Man what they're going to do with
the multiplayer and stuff like that but
by all accounts it's going to be more
Spider-Man and that's great if hellblade
could take what hellblade did in the
first game and expand upon it make that
combat really feel really good and like
a a deep combat and have it be more you
know a lot of the stuff that happened
Hellboy One was in her mind right and
and that was stylistic and cool but it
kind of does feel like he's actually
fighting a real war now so it's going to
be back and forth between what's
happening in the real world and what's
happening in her mind
um so it just seems like the scope of
the game is so much bigger that it yeah
to me they do it right it can't stand
Toe to Toe with those bigger AAA games
coming out at the back end of the year
so yeah the Xbox pull that off massive
year so we'll see what happens man all
about I think Starfield is kind of what
what kind of is going to set the trend
on what potentially could happen when
that happens or whatever so yeah I was
gonna say and for people uh I you know
those came from our patreon I put it in
the in the car in the chat so uh
definitely go over there and support if
you guys want for the five dollar two
you can ask any show we have every week
questions and um you know King and me
are doing reactions to about anything
right now it seems like we're doing
mainly anime uh and that's the seven
dollars here the two dollar you can make
us react to something no doubt uh you
know it's mainly me and King right now
now like I said to the people messaging
me Cog and soft can do small reactions
but it can't be full episodes like 10
minute thing out out the door thing yeah
no no doubt man salute salute let's get
it into these topics right quick um
attic this is you I can set you up with
the awkward Hogwarts if you want yeah
that's it hold on real quick I got a
couple of support yeah no doubt let's
get this we got a couple that just kind
of jumped in uh we got Dave Ramos your
support we got this I just say oh yeah I
got that already we got Lawrence
Davenport two dollar Super Chat Xbox
series X FIFA 23 Starfield and red fault
each of the games you would take on an
island okay
[Music]
is definitely especially the updated
version David Ramos two dollar Super
Chat series X Witcher 3 Starfield Mario
Kart emulation
then we have curro Vader ten dollars for
the chat greetings from Okinawa keep up
the good work
let's go baby are we International
winning worldwide Lords let's go love it
let's go
then we have Butterball
if you ever get the chance to visit the
Negro League Baseball Museum in in KC it
is a wonderful Museum I have not been I
would love to go and get into that in a
minute in a little bit yep we'll cut up
all right no doubt no doubt so addict
this is you I'll set you up Hogwarts man
a lot of news this week obviously
um the record-breaking
um just kind of PC sales uh the charts
records obviously amidst the controversy
we know there's a lot going on with it
but uh steam DB um which tracks
concurrent players on PC platforms steam
set Hogwarts level this was Saturday had
over 700 um thousand players making it
the second largest player count ever
recorded
um in a 24-hour span and then I have an
update to that actually Benji sales
yesterday said now it's 800 000 plus
concurrent players on Steam for Hogwarts
Legacy absolutely mind-blowing numbers
and there's a very real chance
PlayStation is outperforming PC the game
is also current pushing current gen
Hardware Sales he's expecting uh PR next
week with h from um Warner Brothers with
the Colossal launch sales number and
also that the concurrent number on PC
already means million sold plural on
Steam alone so his expectation for the
platform spit is split is PlayStation PC
then Xbox we've also seen that the game
only Trails uh pubg battle Battlegrounds
um Hogwarts Legacy Total box the eighth
largest Peak on Steam all time and the
third the third it is the third ranked
single player game trailing Elden ring
and cyberpunk which is huge and then as
far as the number on Twitch
1.28 million as far as being streamed on
Twitch according to game developers
making it the highest watch single
player game on the platform and then
what we don't know which was kind of
like the unknown as far as on the the
specific platform splits as far as um
those goals but what I can say I looked
up on
Xbox most gay played and I thought this
was interesting as of today it is
sitting at number six on Xbox gameplay
it's only only behind Roblox Grand Theft
Auto 5 Apex Legends Modern Warfare 2 and
fortnite so this has been a tremendous
week for um Hogwarts Legacy despite you
know the controversy around it I know an
attic you stream the game you play the
game so you know what's your thoughts
it's your topic
it's a good game I think that people
you know even with all the the stuff
that's going on with it that this game
is it's gonna break records I think
this is definitely a game of the air
Contender uh depending on what's
currently out now now I don't know how
starfield's gonna end up or Spider-Man
but I'd be very surprised if I didn't
see this as a nominee at the interview
um and you know it might even win
because Starfield and them are good but
this got that Harry Potter name behind
and people I'm seeing another thing I'm
seeing a lot of women are playing this
game too uh you know it's it's
interesting it's interesting the way
things are going it's interesting how
many people are playing this on Steam
because they generally drop stuff really
fast and it's been like that for
they had like 300 000 consecutive people
from the deluxe edition the three-day
access the hourly access so
like 300 000 minimum people
bought the game to have the three-day
access like it's crazy it's it's it's
insane the uh hard guess you need just
gave away you should have gave that to
me
I was looking for one of them codes
so always helping out the community
yeah so I I think it's a good game I
think that you know this one game show
like this I get I I get happy because
it's like I've always said
mostly there are occasions where this
doesn't apply you make good games people
are gonna play it it's just how it is
you make good games people are going to
play it you know obviously there's uh
difference when it comes to like smaller
Niche titles like you know xcom's a
great game but only turn-based people
really gonna get down on that but it
sold well in the turn-based community
this this game applies to a lot of
people and it's selling because that it
imply obviously you got a little bit of
people picking up at a spike for you
know the stuff going on Twitter yeah but
this game was going to sell well
regardless what's going on and what's
funny is I was talking to uh that was on
fun speculations podcast a couple days
ago
and we talked about you know what
there's a lot of people that picked up
this game over the stuff going on
Twitter and they're like and it turned
out well for them because it turned out
to be a good game it's like oh look man
I I picked this despite people and and
it's actually good like I'm actually
enjoying it like because I saw people on
Twitter say that they expected you know
the copy they bought that they were just
gonna play for an hour and never touch
again because they didn't a lot of
people didn't expect this game to be
good and you know I think that shows
that it doesn't matter what kind of
Studio you have
good talent and well-directed people in
that studio can make any game good up
until now these people have made nothing
but small licensed stuff for Disney
they've never made anything remotely on
the scale of this game and now looking
with the nav probably one of the most
sold games this year if Call of Duty
does not come out this year this might
be the most sold game this year I want
to ask you because you streamed it and
you know my understanding from you is
you're not really like a Harry Potter
correct me if I'm wrong if you're like a
Harry Potter Universe person but um I
want to know like well that's what I
figured so I figured me you kind of hit
it like what is it because I want to
talk about the game itself like what was
it about the game that's really got you
like you know they may have one game's
gorgeous
yeah because I'm not really I don't care
about like the the behind the semantics
thing when it comes to Harry Potter uh
you know I have friends that are
obsessed with that Lord I just seen the
movie that's exactly that's as far as
that's going it took me years to fight
to watch the prequel ones and I can't
remember what those are called but it
took me years to watch those and it's
just like look you it's like I said over
and over again
developers and people that write uh
developers and people that do movies and
TV shows about games you respect the
lore people will show up you respect the
Lord for Harry Potter you made sure that
the atmosphere felt like Harry Potter
you made sure that even the way they
talk feels like Harry it seems like
you're pointing seems like your point
see it's like yeah you know subliminal
pretty here
it seemed like it seems like it's a
specific property
was that the last of us people of those
subliminals at the Halo people
look bad look well we ain't gonna really
go too much into the last of us but
besides that last episode I ain't gonna
lie I ain't been happy with that
you know go ahead and go go watch me on
um on on RNR with the Lords of being
King yeah I mean King argued for 45
minutes on that show
let's get a kiss move man I want to get
your thoughts on it man Hogwarts Legacy
obviously we know this this controversy
we've talked about that I know it's you
you know what I mean and everything
that's going on there but I want to talk
about first the success of what you're
seeing and people really supporting and
seeing that they really like the game
almost record level
um engagement that we're seeing so where
you at kid
yeah the success of the the game is it
is a good game
um what I can say about that I'm I guess
I'm somewhat surprise I I shouldn't be
surprised about the success because it
is Harry Potter it was a a polarizing
event you know you know with you know
this cyber that side
um the game like the team what it was
doing because a lot of these numbers are
pre-regular release yes the most
expensive release so it's like geez
these dudes are banking so uh in this
team not known for making the best games
they made like Toy Story three and cars
they don't make in-depth games uh you
know they're like the par for the core
all right what movies coming out okay we
got the license for that we'll do this
right the games you probably won't buy
um but
so this there's a lot of factors riding
on is I think uh some of the controversy
controversary help uh the IP obviously
the Harry Potter universe is Big that
helped
um
and I don't think anyone really
anticipated like this uh doing better
than let's say like a
like a Batman Universe game like we got
them Knights I still think this game is
going to do better than you know the
suicide squad thing so
um I think um overall though like I
think once people got into the game
um Beyond you know the controversy and
they got to actually play it it was like
oh this is actually kind of hot like
this is actually kind of a dope game and
um like I'll tell you guys this game
wasn't on my radar like you know what I
mean uh you know I like to buy into some
of the controversies I was like yeah
yeah I'll support it whatever but um as
far as the um it wasn't on my radar and
then addict said you know you got it and
I'm like okay I'll give it a try and I
haven't been able to put it down like
I've been trying to sneak ways to play
the game right like and just like all
right I got some time here let me you
know try to get some side quests out of
the way let me get some of the flight
schools out of the way it's it's a dope
game man and and I am actually happy I'm
curious to see what those numbers come
out like I don't know you mentioned
something about I guess next week
they're supposed to be talking about it
um
because how it's appearing on like steam
twitch uh the obviously Xbox and
Playstation Marketplace and then every
time I log into the app and I'm seeing
this is how many people are playing it
of your friends list yeah are playing
the game I'll tell you one thing let's
go quick story and I'll let you um get
your bars off I went into work
um and my colleague was like
hey um have you um have you played the
uh Hogwarts game yet and I'm like I'm
like yeah yeah yeah yeah and
it's not a gamer just a like regular
girl like you know what I mean and she
was like yeah yeah she was like I've
been playing what school did what school
did you get oh that that that's a
judgment Zone be careful be careful what
school you pick I heard it's bad yeah
what real quick smooth I let the um the
chat answer the two questions at the
beginning and they tricked me into being
Slytherin
so let's finish the story because I
wonder what happened so I was like I was
like oh because I couldn't pronounce it
I'm not a Harry Potter personally
Slytherin and I was like yeah she was
like oh yeah yeah then we start getting
to the conversation and she's like
she's like taking my time and I was
talking about like hey yeah the only
thing is I like I like the leveling
system but right now my character looked
Goofy
because of the outfit number tell me why
she taught me how to put my outfit on so
that I could keep my love I'm like what
bro it's what do you say that because
right
my friend Brittany is a huge uh Harry
Potter fan she went out and bought a
next-gen console hasn't had one since
like the original Xbox just to play it
goes to show you the power of shot the
Lord lockout in the chat like the power
of the medium the book because again I I
don't know anything about the lore and
to see the non-gamers gravitate toward
it and the way that it is is pretty
tremendous I want to get uh Lord K
Asanti in the building I know his time
is limited but I want to respect so my
check sir and uh yes sir yeah what do
you hear me yeah I can hear you down
like what are you feeling about the the
success of Hogwarts Legacy oh I I uh and
I've been talking about it you know I've
been I've been online about it and I've
been I've been uh tweeting about it and
whatnot first off let's shout out to the
Fades you should oh shout out to the
fade bro yo I gotta hit it up for one
second let's go and I have to say
because I didn't pick up the game yet
but I have some people who are playing
it the representation on people of color
and hair and texture and styles very
impressive only second only to forbidden
West yes forbidden West salute yes
absolutely only to forbidden West it's
Forest inclusion the the level of detail
on this character creator is impressive
continue sir yeah so I I won't go too
far deep into the into the into the the
the conspiracies and all that what's
going on but but since since you know I
roll with the man who who swims in
conspiracies we think it's a Psy out the
whole thing
it is a feature not a bug and because of
that a lot more ears are hearing about
it now because it had it come out and
there wasn't that much of a of a huge
kerfuffle in in the industry right you
probably probably would have came and
wrote those who loved it would have
loved it and kind of moved on but
because of all the the drama it is now
being talked about but the best part
about it is usually when those things
those things happen and you go and you
play it and you you whatever this medium
is whatever other some director said
something crazy about a movie or some
actor said something and then you watch
the movie and you go okay it's all right
this is far better than any ridiculous
like uh uh drama surrounding it the
substance of the game is unusually good
real quick uh I come to it from a
non-real huge Harry Potter fan right uh
I am to it as I am like like so if I'm a
Star Wars fan my favorite is Rogue one
okay if that makes sense okay to the
people right to the realm you understand
that I like the World building I want I
want to leave the old the old uh
monikers behind gotcha so a lot of
people go I don't like this Harry Potter
movie the Harry Potter game right
Harry's not even anywhere in this right
and for those who have seen like the
movies the the the what are the
Fantastic Beasts and all that they don't
connect I personally believe this is
their Rogue one moment where they where
they transcend the the the initial
reason why people came there you know
the the kids that were the the center of
the of of that universe and now they're
no longer the center they're not even
there but as a gamer this thing has just
so much for you it is just so
entertaining and fun and there's just so
many so many systems upon systems upon
systems they just keep adding more to it
and it seems like they've spent a lot of
time really really dialing in the fun
and as you're saying also I honestly
think they saw the relative uh issues
coming with with the IP and all that so
they took the time right and every
character you meet is the best version
of themselves I don't care who you're
talking about they they're respected
they are they're treated with respect
the uh the first character I met was a
Ugandan character oh I'm gonna sticklet
I'm a stickler for for for for a
language and accents because I'm African
let's go they do it right which is a
rarity that's my smoke that's my smoke
for for for uh for uh Black Panther they
don't do the the access accent
I love this distracted I'm glad you said
that okay so I really appreciated what
they did there with it I think it's
absolutely fantastic
um folks who are like I'm not with this
IP or I don't know it this is
specifically for you if you're a gamer
and you're not a Harry Potter person
you'll still find the love here because
there's just so much to love there's so
much fun stuff to do that has absolutely
nothing to do with the prior history or
the why a heavy history that that it's
from so I personally think it's great um
I will give it a little bit of smoke
let's go and that's the reason why I say
there's some psyops here because I feel
like they'd be valid criticism maybe of
the late game getting a bit repetitive
okay or the fact that it's still kind of
really badly optimized no matter where
you play it you know but you don't hear
too much of that because of the psyops
that's taking over the gotcha gotcha
like I jumped in I got a deal on it on
PC PC was was a little garbage these
days as I do more research I'm finding
out that's more and video folks that
seem to be having the issues Xbox
yeah I'm on my series my CX I got my VR
beautiful but I'm also going from 60
frames to like oh you go there okay okay
so you're losing the frames a little bit
oh yeah I double dipped and I still
didn't get the best experience but I'm
still there okay that tells you the kind
of game we're talking about eventually
it'll all the technical issues will be
worked out I'm sure okay but the game at
its core is it's so much fun I'm five
hours in on the X on the Xbox five hours
in on the PC I'm rolling two different
characters and every time I'm playing
I'm like I just want to keep playing it
it's a great great experience absolutely
absolutely salute appreciate you Insight
on that then we got my man the muffin
man save the games media my guy turn
based fellow Brethren you don't even
know we ain't talking about turbase
right now but um yeah like what's your
thought or just the success of Hogwarts
I don't know I don't know if you picked
it up or not but just get your feedback
so I haven't picked it up uh first of
all uh it's it's not really an IP that
I've ever been Associated or connected
to so so this wasn't really anything I
wanted but everyone I talked to is like
this game is phenomenal this game has to
be in Game of the Year conversations and
I think that is what surprised me the
most is because like I I just didn't
expect that right it's one of those
you hear the controversy and what you
wherever you fall on that all right
we're not we're not here to talk about
that
um it was one of those things where I
was like okay I bet the game's gonna
come out it's gonna be pretty decent
right and then it was I think it's like
86 on open critic or whatever and I'm
like oh wow this is a this is a banger
game this is the amount of plate I
actually feel like that that's a that's
a couple numbers lower than I would have
gave it well I mean you got the you got
the one out of ten score in there uh two
we will discuss we will discuss but
regardless it's it's everyone I talk to
has given me fomo man it's one of those
things where I'm like do I is this a
game I need to jump into and chaosante's
selling me more on it where he's like if
even if you're not a Harry Potter Guy
this is something that you're probably
gonna enjoy right this is something you
can jump into it's just a really well
constructed RPG and for me I'm like oh
that that's right up my alley I love me
some RPGs that we can get lost into
um I would love to be in Slytherin by
the way
[Laughter]
but the sales and just the the player
base the records this game is setting
it's like it clearly shows me that
despite the controversy like the
majority of people probably have no idea
about this controversy right they just
see like this Harry Potter game is
amazing it's blowing up I gotta pick it
up and they're losing themselves in it
like there's a reason it was the most
watched or streamed game on Twitch yeah
everyone's going to it there's it it has
even after all these years some sort of
relevancy and Stranglehold amongst
people that like I don't even know how
to explain the power of this IP and it's
more than I ever thought it was going to
do yeah no same thing I'll jump real
quick just two things two things because
if I didn't the chat would kill me go
for it one full F40 FPS locked on Steam
deck y'all know it
and oh yeah and Carter and Cog is gonna
kill me because this is the game that
got that you had no problem playing
those games when he was on Steam deck
it's locked car go kill you
gonna kill me because I've kind of like
put down midnight Sons
but I had no intentions initially to
pick it up and I was like damn like
everybody you know you get the photo
like everybody seem to have a [__] I
was at my midnight sons and Hi-Fi rush
and all this other stuff back and you
seeing what's going on so yeah salute
salute to you on that that's impressive
um so let me get your thoughts on this
or no yeah yes I'm sorry let's get your
thoughts first before yes yes uh
it isn't often that
a game that you see
that excites you by what you see
actually lives up to it when it comes
out any game like it's hard it's hard
when you see first time right
um the first time I saw this game and I
was like wow they're really going for it
in terms of the lore in terms of the
World building in terms of separating it
from Harry Potter itself and just taking
everything about that world that fantasy
world and and putting that in the hands
of players I'm like this is too
ambitious like everyone else said this
team has made Toy Story 3 shout out to
Maddie I know he loves it but you know
um but this is not a team that's known
for making this type of game
and for them to come out and hit it out
of the park so thoroughly yeah
is super impressive and for me I haven't
had a chance to play it nearly as much
as I as I wanted to to casante's point
when I saw it on Steam deck and they
said it verified I'm like what yeah I
was like huh excuse me
um and yes I locked 40.
it really is yeah
um
is super impressive and to me
again the controversy the controversy
has always been at the center of this
and
this is what happens when you attempt to
shut something down
on the basis of
whatever
extreme moral arguments that are
difficult to sort of prove in their
exactness
and and and what happens is that you're
gonna do two things you're gonna push
people who are going to push up against
those those that thinking you're going
to push them to go through Extreme
Measures to promote the game right by
multiple copies give away multiple
copies things of that nature
in addition to that you we tend to
forget we're in this bubble in the
gaming space that is not and the gaming
space and Twitter
and that bubble is completely removed
from the real world yeah oh you'd be
like Echo chamber that Twitter is yeah
there you go Oh I thought Twitter
represent the whole world everybody
feels like that I know I guess everybody
within it believes that okay and then
I'm glad we brought that to my attention
that that does not represent the real
world and then we touch grass and we've
realized it's a different thing and the
vast majority of people don't care about
the controversy or have you know made
their peace with it and and
and decided to either support or not
support and again I will always say I
respect everybody's right to support or
not support absolutely for whatever the
reasons they deem they deem important to
them absolutely respect your right to do
that yes
not going to go further into that that's
what it is a great game is getting is
just due
and
I'm glad I'm so glad because it
it really is heartening to see that
reasonable Minds have prevailed here and
we've rewarded this hard-working team
who has never done anything of this
scope or magnitude
to go out there and create this
definitive Harry Potter experience or
excuse me Hogwarts experience yes right
we keep calling that Harry Potter
experience and it's not it's removed
from that it's telling it's giving us
the entire world of it and that is in
any situation from any team whether a
naughty dog does this one of the biggest
studios in the world for the uh for them
to accomplish this on this level
is super impressive and that needs to be
called out and for me I'm just glad uh
the conversations that are going around
my game of the year I believe it is it
should be a candidate I do not think
that when we get there
are you implying that there is no way
this game could win game of the year
because of circumstances there will be
circumstances there will be unfair
and you know hopefully a fan vote or you
know or something like that but it just
kind of feels like
the opportunities that are going to be
there to continue to try to shut this
down will be taken by those who care to
do that
um
so we'll see we'll see
um but I'm just I I'm glad for the
accolades I'm sad for the the things
that are happening with people getting
bullied off of streams and things of
that nature yeah it is it's just
ridiculous it's so it's just ridiculous
but I'm I'm glad this has outshined that
for the most part yeah I'll jump in um
what's that song I think that you know
for me was definitely surprising you
know to see I mean we saw signs of it
because the pre-order numbers were just
like insane on Steam prior to release so
I I saw that there was definitely you
know in anticipation there and hype for
the game and obviously we know the
controversy We're Not Gonna not you know
dance around it you know obviously we
have my man tie on who represented the
other side we had a great respectful
discussion you know what I mean when we
heard each other out and I thought that
was you know really constructive I I
think that you know for me I gotta be
honest with y'all like this was outside
of the news of the game this was a very
tough week for me because I started to
see a lot of the nastiness on on Twitter
and social media in reference to that
and you know there's some people who are
friends of mine who you know really got
abused for either say they bought the
game reviewed the game shout out to my
bed my man is North up you know what I
mean I do last word progress whatever be
IG I had people that I've known for like
five years unfollowed me over yeah
saying I'm playing it and and you know
we got to be careful with the moral High
Ground stuff and like we said we we
understand someone's right to not
support we could we fully understand
that but we also understand that some
people one want to play a video game
right and they were highly anticipating
this universe and I just saw a lot of
nastiness you know shout out to my man
pyro you know you receive death threats
you know I've seen people ridiculous put
up you know who's streaming that game to
go attack people who are actually
streaming it and the thing I said I said
it on Duke is like we we have to be
careful let's get this balls over I got
you we got to be careful of attacking
people in such a way that we end up
becoming the thing we are rallying
against OS absolutely and you've got to
be careful and that's again we respect
everyone and the reason why I said also
you got to be careful with playing moral
High Ground is because there's a lot of
Insidious things with a lot of these
companies that we all that we all love
and have things that are attached
associated with so to have a moral
conscience is becoming very difficult in
this day and age not making excuses you
know if you choose not to great but just
be careful of attacking bullying people
if they choose to disagree with you or
thinking it doesn't mean that they
doesn't necessarily mean that they hate
you right it just means that hey they
just want to play this game they want to
stay out of that you know what I mean
and that's fine too so I think it's we
got to be more careful to agree to
disagree sometimes and do it
respectfully and that's what you become
you become what you're what you're rally
what's your rallying against and an
addict I give it right to you but I know
yes you know I want to shout out a
couple developers again I think it's
Troy Levitt who worked on the game and
um he mentioned you know specifically
how because another thought process was
like Hey and even and I fell victim to
it it's like hey if you buy this game
are you Pro you know giving the end the
supporter to someone who has a view that
you don't align with with JK Rowling
right so he made a good point and he was
just like you know as a game developer
who worked on Hogwarts Legacy he just
wouldn't say that that thought process
is wrong he said many members of the dev
team have compensation packages tied to
the games reception and performance so
sales of the game do in fact support the
devs and then there's also discussion
about you know is it really not saying
that she doesn't get anything from it
from a top level but the the actual
relationship there it's a good
discussion I highly recommend people you
know go to his timeline I'm even
educating myself as I learn more about
this process but guys before we pass an
addict I think we all have to remember
this and I
the world that JK Rowling has created
feel feel about her how you will will
long outlive her
good point
and it's going to be there for
Generations right and it's going to mean
different things to different
Generations
I grew up loving Dr Seuss all overview
that's a good one that's a good one
and rolled doll doll The Witches yes
doctors anything Dr Seuss yeah when you
get older and you understand the history
of these writers and where they come
from and their feelings on societal
things and whatnot now you got to make a
choice right and the choice I made is
The Works that they created were so sort
of base level all-encompassing about
just life lessons that young kids should
learn
and they're gone they're gone they're no
longer here
I'm going to take what I need in my life
from what they from their works and move
forward with that in a positive way
whatever you feel about the individual
that made the art
they're human and they will not be here
forever and it's on you to take that art
and grow it as you see fit
so that's why I'm always an advocate of
separating the art from the individual
because art is always subjective it is
always what you extract from it that is
important
so for me
like I said before it is I am so so
happy that this team is getting their
Just Desserts
um for taking this art that this woman
created and moving with it in in
directions that
maybe she never anticipated maybe she
did yeah no there's well well said solve
as always so I always spitting you you
become the preacher of the black cat
lately people just love when you preach
I want to give it back to attic I know I
interrupted him you wanted something he
wanted to say and then I wanted to ask
after you go at it I wanted to bring it
back one time as far as we got to talk
about it the wire review you know the
wired review excuse me and um that that
feedback there so attic suffers you know
shout out to I can't remember the
individual that posted it uh it's the
one that you shared me Cog that I shared
in the chat a couple weeks ago what is
his name oh you talk about uh the mighty
Keith yeah Mighty Keith yeah
shout out to him where he's like look
like I get it you guys are taking a
stand
but what's this game different like that
she got so many uh streams of Revenue
Disney don't be boycotting Marvel no one
be doing that she got plenty of things
that she does outside of this one game
and made good points like because it's
easy
time that if there was true people
rallying against the cause there are
other ways to go about it as opposed to
targeting this specifically to vilify a
group of people is that yeah it's just
like you know when when people know that
she has deals with Disney
I'm not gonna go watch a Marvel movie or
a Marvel show until she's took out of
the equation why has that never happened
it's just one of those things where it's
like look this is not a black and white
scenario like this is a very gray area
it's like for instance great you know
if we had that kind of mentality where
if it's morally wrong on any kind of
shape or show we would not be doing
anything Sony had racist emails years
ago like it's like we you can't get away
from it it's everywhere like moral
Hardware real quick for me yes uh
everybody had a problem with forespoken
I had a problem before spoken for
different reasons and I stood on my
Square on that and I will continue to
send my Square on that and every time I
see Barrett I feel like throwing tomato
at the screen I feel you all the
shocking and driving does not sit right
with me you know what I'm saying it's a
video game if you're gonna be a gamer
and you're going to stand on that square
they're going to be very many minimal
amounts of games you can play and if you
are complaining and you're doing it on
Twitter
yeah and with your iPhone yeah or you
drive a Volkswagen where are you going
yeah I mean okay Asanti how is that
iPhone that was uh produced here how is
that yeah
to to speak on it you know what that the
Twitter is about it's right
um
it's okay to not support something it's
not okay to tell other people not to
support it yeah yeah
give them the tools that you feel that
they need but it's up to them at the end
of the day not to do it right and at the
end of the day I don't like you know for
the people that know the uh the the uh
the woman that does reviews girlfriend
reviews and people going to her twitch
Channel and they had to stop the stream
because it was so bad and they're
getting so much hate they had to stop
the stream and it's just like I'm not
I'm not for that because that's
harassment that's bullying and harassing
people just because you and them have
different opinions on something that's
not one of those things where it's like
you know what I think that you know we
could come to a middle ground no it's
one of those things where you're gonna
believe what I believe or you're gonna
get up out of here right that's what I
see yeah and that's what we have to be
careful of and like again you know I I
saw I think even Travis's review in
Nigeria now we're going to switch the
reviews real quick you know he even put
in his review like hey we understand
that there was a lot of controversy or
right I'm surrounding this game and the
decision for people not to want to
support this game but all we want to do
is review on the merits of this game is
it the pro is this game fun and to see
my brother get attacked in the way he
did for that statement it really
disheartened me you know it really
disheartened me and again I'm all for
transparency I'm all for anyone who says
yo Cog I'm part and I got love for my
trans brothers and sisters like hey I'm
not picking this up right I can respect
it thank you thank you K shut that down
yeah thank you I can respect it you know
what I'm saying so it's like that's all
good but again at the same time when
someone says hey I'm still picking this
up you know for reasons whatever reason
they may be to to go on the attack that
that pause a bit much so let's get into
it the other part of it was obviously it
was a wide review I don't know many of
you are aware of where you know the game
received a one out of ten you know one
out of ten and um it was a lot a lot of
pushback there and for in reference to
the community so I just wanted to get
you know let's start I guess let's start
with um sorry kid and you know I don't
know if you saw it
um what's your thoughts there's no way
he didn't see it yeah I was stupid kid
saw it but you know I just I want to
speak about it do you think that's fair
or or are you outside of that no um I
didn't read it I just saw the score
um because I was like if you're really
it's not worth reading I did I know your
intentions If You're Gonna Go literally
one out of ten
um so I didn't bother reading it I just
like all right he's whoever uh is
responsible forever review is doing
whatever they're doing for the cause the
show hey I'm not you know I'm still
protesting
um which is it is what it is I don't
think
I don't think protesting
um
when these controversial events come up
I don't think that should have anything
to do
with the product you're reviewing I
don't think it should like even when I
think the dude from idea to also put in
like that disclaimer I don't think it's
necessary you don't need it you don't
have to explain yourself oh why you're
reviewing a game like I I can't stand
this whole literally their jobs like no
no yeah yeah it's like I don't like this
whole um like apologetic thing for just
doing hey oh well I gotta walk I gotta
walk on the eggshells to talk about this
because I might upset these people no no
I can't stand that I can't stand that
way of thinking the way we operate today
so when I saw that review I was like
well this is a bum I would never take a
review from like wiring things isn't
that the same people who gave High doc
Hi-Fi some points because Xbox didn't
release those games in 2022.
oh Metro so that's I was like then what
is what are you reviewing for like what
is what is the rules for reviewing games
I don't understand how the editor or
like the the editor-in-chief whatever
whoever they how they go through their
review process a lot allowed that review
to be published
instructed from the website for the
website no I I hate I hear when you're
coming let's get my mind on them you
know I know that this has been a bit of
controversy you know did you see it and
where do you stand on it the wired
review uh giving the game a one out of
ten yeah so I have a I have a big
problem with this actually I think this
is a a big issue in terms of making
games journalism look bad it makes it
look like an absolute joke if I'm being
candid um because you have you have
other you have smaller independent sites
like Lords of gaming you have the season
or friends over season gaming who put
out great content and don't get you know
given every single game like something
like wired do obviously being a bigger
publication right and then you have a
person who looking at their most recent
articles that they write things like
best vibrators to use or whatever yeah
the person who yeah I did see that it
brings into question like one is is this
person qualified to even be reviewing
this for for the publication and then
when you actually read the review it is
the person could have written wrote this
entire thing without playing the game
not one time did I read us a word they
wrote down that I was like this matches
what I'm hearing from anyone else on the
end no one else is saying anything close
to what you're saying and even then they
say oh the game is mid okay if it's mid
tell me how you got to a one then you
the only way you get there is your
feelings about the IP holder right which
is which you again you can put in your
feelings about the IP holder but if
you're assigning a numerical score that
is meant to represent the value of the
game based on the game play based on
what the developers did a one should be
for a game that fundamentally does not
work you can't turn the game on so when
I when I see this I I cannot fathom how
Pub if I was a publisher you're not
getting enough you are not getting a
code you you're done you're you have
shown me that you are not a credible
site why would I give something to you
in the future going forward it's I'm not
saying oh they should have given it a
score just because they got a code
that's not how that's not how it
actually works but when you are clearly
such an outlier from anyone else
it just brings up serious ethical
journalism questions for me every
publisher should blackball them for that
because now because that means no
publisher is safe from some like from
like a bias pretty yeah pretty much
that's targeting so in the protection of
WB Games I think every publisher should
look at that and say hey we can't really
be messing with these guys like that so
skirt like let them buy their review
code or something that's crazy good when
it cut like the conversation we had
earlier uh about you know blacklisting
and stuff like that these are the
scenarios where people deserve to be
blacklisted because they're not taking
it as a game they're taking it as
something else to feel some other agenda
they have this there's no way shape or
form when you play this game this is a
one out of ten it's just realistic you
know if they wanted to give their
opinion on it and they'd give a
statement like you know kids will be
brought up the IGN they I'm more okay
with that because at least you're you
know this is my statement but this isn't
the game that you're referring to people
tell you know you're fumbling her money
you're giving her money she already
rents she can do whatever she wants it
don't matter what this game takes and
money it's just it's it's frustrating
because the writer's room she's not in
the writer's room she's not good she's
not the head of Studio Point absolutely
the point and then and then the thing
that let me just interrupt one quick the
thing that is really interesting is to
me that I don't see a lot talking about
is I feel like The devs Avalanches is
the dance correct
um they seem to be taking a stance
against the overall thought process of
JK it says that hey we have you know a
trans character in the game you know we
have things that to make this universe
seem more inclusive yeah and but what
happens is that now people they start to
Pivot to different things that they
outraged about the uh the perceived
anti-Semitism with the with the goblins
and stuff like that um the fact that the
the the trans character for some people
isn't represented properly or whatever
uh I've heard that apparently did you
see that a picture of what perceives
looked just like Jay Rowling being like
catching on fire the picture like like
they did a lot of stuff in this to be
like look we don't agree with her
opinions and I don't feel like none of
that's talked about at all like
whatsoever they're like it doesn't
matter what the devs say it doesn't
matter if this is the only game they've
ever been given the chance to make
something on this scale damn them we
don't care about them even the naming
conventions because the naming
conventions the name names oftentimes
sort of point point to kind of like the
the disposition of the character or you
know or things like that uh and there's
there's certain names there's like
something about shackles and things like
that I mean well I I remember seeing uh
I think the trans character in the game
is their their name is sirona oh of
course they have sir at the start
because they gotta be they gotta say it
I'm like I think it's wild reaching here
I think there was even some in reference
to that the whole size behind that is in
reference correct me for wrong because I
don't know Harry Potter's universe but
it refers to some type of
deity or or something like that is where
I heard the origin of that name was
supposed to supposed to be in a positive
yeah right no it's it's not even in the
in universes the the name is based on uh
yeah it's some it means something about
women it means something about like but
something very like positive and
empowering and empowering that's what I
yeah that's what I I had heard from it
when as far as the reasoning behind it
but again it's interpretation and stuff
like that but attic finish and I
definitely get K his bars off
it's just like certain scenarios like
this I agree with King uh kid you know
uh it's like when I brought up earlier
over that you know I I love the industry
I want the industry to to thrive uh like
I said sometimes I feel like
if the criticism is valid that's my only
issue you know earlier when people are
getting blacklisted if the criticism is
valued I feel like it should be taken as
such but that's not happening and this
is this side's the other adjacent where
this isn't even about the game right and
and the media outlet has used it to get
clicks on because nine times out of ten
most these people don't even care what's
going on they are using that ins that
instance to generate Revenue off of the
clicks on going to their website off of
this then just I agree smooth you know
everyone Xbox Sony they should all look
at this website and be like you are
manipulating the review system
Metacritic should have kicked them off
there the moment they try to do it
because that's manipulating the the
review system that is the definition of
doing it yeah it's a very very
interesting uh time we're in right now
let's just say that because something
let's get get your bars sir obviously
the wired review caught some headlines
you know one one out of ten well indeed
it did what's your thoughts I read I
read my most of it caught the broad
Strokes of it and and they too well I
wouldn't say to their credit but they're
not even shy about about basically
saying that they're using this as a
vehicle to to you know to Rally rally
the the community against this game
right uh um um and I won't go too far
into it but basically like one of their
head one of their basic talking points
is that the game industry is far queerer
than people think it is right and and
because of that I guess that's their
justification for using this piece of
art for the the agenda whether good or
bad that they're trying they're they're
trying to put forth right and I don't
know man the whole thing is like the
panel has expertly said the whole thing
just breaks the idea of what a review
process and what these folks are there
for I mean I understand that some folks
say stand on your Square either you
either you you you stand with with the
controversy or you stand against yeah
you should have said I'm not reviewing
the game that's where I'm standing
no absolutely absolutely 100 because if
we're going down that path I've already
I've already made my my feelings known
about about games like forespoke there
are a lot of the the game industry is
far blacker than you know but you don't
see us on the picket line do you know
what I'm saying like there are there
have been issues and there will be
systematic issues with Humanity for as
long as we are here and we're working on
it every day does not mean that it gives
you the justifiable right to use this
this medium and this name that wired a
very prestigious name very prestigious
you know uh uh a very well-known
well-appreciated brand that usually
provides a good service for this agenda
if you will right yeah and the thing
that really gets me and and and and and
Lord addict said that you see I did put
the Lord
yeah
what what he's saying what I agree with
is when all this controversy came up it
became a hot button topic right but then
when you look at the actual content it
is far removed it elevates right Beyond
even the games that you've been playing
for years that have their weird agendas
that people just don't say anything
about they took their time to make sure
that every person was very well cared
for in this so if you come to this game
with said a controversy you will be
surprised to see nah they actually flip
on the flip you know uh to me I say I
say black hair is low hanging fruit they
even went far and did something there
right they they tried their best to
speak to anyone and everyone that is
being represented in this game so that
if it happens that the controversy
brings you here you won't see it and go
okay it's Justified right instead if if
you're if you're clear-eyed and you're
looking at it and you just don't know
anything about it and you're coming in
coming into it trying to educate
yourself you will be bowled over and
surprised by how much time and effort
they took to dispel this this false
narrative that it's all about this
agenda right they did great work here
right and because of that wired yeah you
know it's one of those things but but
I've had conversations like similarly
and not to not to this extent but
similarly about how the reviewers and
the community are now like at us at a
Crossroads and they're taking different
paths sometimes look at high on life you
know it comes and it literally it needed
the community to say come on people
review it properly because y'all are
wrong this is happening more and more
and these these specific situations
don't help much right we're we're losing
the thread and and it's it's coming to a
place where people can happily you know
not even pay attention to these reviews
anymore which is a an unfortunate thing
because for a long time now I have loved
you know pouring over all of this stuff
when a great game comes out reading the
reviews watching IGN and all the various
sources you know all the all the the
Indies and the big guys and what they
think doesn't mean it'll it'll
necessarily it'll necessarily tell me
what two or not two by not too bad right
but it's great to hear what the
community has to say and and be part of
that discourse and this poisons the well
it completely just poisons the well and
they knew that and they still did it
anyway so it's it's just unfortunate for
me you know the sad part this is such a
sensitive topic I don't even blame other
companies for not wanting to jump on it
and try to like punish them in any way
shape or form you know you're not
getting review codes from us because you
manipulated the review system because
the moment they do that the moment they
start not getting review copies from
these other things what's going to go on
Twitter they're uh they they're
transphobic companies because they
wouldn't go with our statement so it's
just it's it's sad man it's sad that
companies like that will abuse the the
review system because I honestly do feel
like that review system is flawed it
needs to be restructured and it should
be something that is a guide for people
but to me it's used for clicks it's used
uh for hate and it's and it's sad fun of
being oh sorry to get your bars off on
the review and then I did want to ask
one last question and we'll move on
which is about
um can
um this be like let's say if the the
consensus feel and more people play it
and the more you know reviews come out
and you know people feel it's it's a
good game can it be nominated
for game of theater that was my last box
I mean could it be I mean we'll see your
Panda will it will it be I don't think
it will be I don't think overall in
terms of the in terms of Jeff Keeley
show yeah I don't think it will be I
think even you think it gets a
nomination at any level
it may it may for sure okay
um but maybe not as well I mean I could
because my feeling is this
even
the the uh the outlets that have decided
to review it and try to be as objective
as possible
there's just a pressure there's a
there's an unfortunate pressure that
comes from
these other sentiments that you know
could sway Outlets one way or another to
not even want that smoke right
um I think it's a big difference it's
it's it's it's one Hill to die and when
you say look my job is to review these
games I'm going to review this game and
that's it you can you know you can't
really call me out you can choose to
call me out for it but you'd be dead
wrong because I'm doing my job and I'm
being objective especially if I'm in
first off and the first thing I do is
say hey I acknowledge the controversy
around this right and I'm doing this
because of this and I and I respect
everyone's opinions around it but I'm
doing it because of this you know
but at the end of the year all that
stuff that the award stuff again
so despite the tremendous success
It Is by all of that there's no there's
no scenario I don't see it
at a nomination level I'm not say a win
but at a nomination level I'd be the
first one to stand up and clap I don't
see it
um
I think because I think this gets um
if you think about it right obviously
you know you know how
games have to impact a certain way right
right you know Elder ring when it came
out obviously it's a good game I'm not
trying to compare it in that way but it
was all the things that guys it broke
this right guys broke the Zeitgeist for
like yeah the best selling or the fast
selling of that you know genre of that
time uh breaking into that casual Market
um what Hogwarts seems to be doing is
doing it's a it's a relatively it's a
good game it's at that Mark where it's
like Gotti material I think what was it
last year's Game of the Year not last
year but two years ago was it 87
Metacritic right so um which was uh it
takes two
and it's that early release I like I
don't think it'll win game of the air
but it deserves a nomination because
let's let the rest of the year play out
and see what happens right and we know
it's a big year yeah but I guess my
question to to narrow it down even
further let's just say it doesn't win
game of the year my question is do you
think it can be because of the climate
and the controversy do you think it
could even be allowed to be nominated in
any category yes you know why why
because this is one of the most diverse
games that come out this year diverse
characters so if you want to first they
want to boycott the game for one thing
but look why this Horizon forbidden West
get praised all the time oh because of
the diversity of characters there's a
whole lot of diversity in this game that
covers almost every basis
but to my point I think I I forget to
get like is it
for we understand there's a lot of
politics business relationships
and the fact that some feel by even
nominating you condone and from a
business standpoint is an entity and I
hate to put them on a spot like this
like the game awards can they be strong
enough to withstand something like that
based on the current outrage we see by
people saying that hey if you even cover
this game you are in support of it that
is some of the mindset the industry the
industry like uh like solve said and
like uh okay Sante said I think even
like you said the industry needs to
learn to separate the freaking get uh
the the art from the the artist then if
that's the case
they all got to apply that rule and when
they're being critical and like all
right let's be realistic let's be fair
um when you're assessing these games and
nominating these games at some point the
politics either if you're gonna go with
the politics or not go to politics it
has to leave and it has to come down to
the product itself the problem is is
it's probably like 50 50.
it's going to be easy like see it's hard
to bully the whole internet
you know that's a massive amount of
websites the massive amount of people
you can't and not to mention monies in
there with sales
what if you don't get that sponsorship
what if we find out if you put hot words
on that screen that's why I said that's
why I said a fan vote sure
the people actually vote on the games
that are being nominated so fair vote
and that's it that's all they came
through your paddle domination it's just
gonna it's gonna start let's go it's
gonna determine if Jeff is okay with
that smoke or not and part of me thinks
he might be part of me thinks he might
not be it just depends on how it's going
towards the end of the year now if
something else pops off and people
forget about Hardware slugsley to a
point where it's not the the prime
center of attention maybe if it's around
that time do we know if Jeff has said
anything about the game has he talked
about the game since it launched as he
said if he hasn't then you got your
answer there okay that's the issue right
that is unfortunately the issue and and
I I you know all respect to to Jeff
Keeley I love what he does in this
industry I think he's a necessary
unnecessary stalwart of this industry
but we call it the kilis for a reason
right it's I've always had a problem
with the the before Game Awards just the
product because that that seems to
insinuate that it is all of ours the
definitive yeah yeah I'm I'm looking it
is the Achilles you know what I mean
like and as much as I love it and I will
watch it every time they have it like it
there are relationships that we know
that are built up over years obviously
there's money changing hands it's it's a
tough call to make because we've all
like you know
it's it's hard to establish it's hard to
establish this as a as something moving
forward when they themselves you've seen
them be put in a hot seat because they
will they will uh uh push up the awards
part but then in in implementation you
see that they get short shrift anyway
because of relationships and we've seen
this happen before so when it comes to
this specifically this part I honestly
don't think we should we should or
should not give Keely the smoke because
he will do what he will do and that's
what what is necessary for the business
I think us us as people should should
probably move so I find more the award
ceremony rather than the Achilles as the
addict I got some information too I'm
looking at Jeff keeley's Twitter and you
write songs
but I just got shout out I got some
information just set my way just now the
game awards account February 12th that
is today at 2 30. Hogwarts Legacy is out
this weekend are you playing what do you
think that is big from the game awards
Twitter account to even put that out
with the garage door that that's kind of
putting yeah I mean but there there is
something to the the pr aspect of that
it's a game to get to Gage
I mean like like
is it safe he's a businessman he
understands you know one he understands
that he has a Stranglehold on this you
don't want to do anything to get for
that strangle hole to be loosened right
so Jeff is honestly he's he's not about
ruffling the wrong feathers and staying
and dying on a hill that's gonna cost
him this show and this popularity so so
yeah yeah so all I want to say is if you
really care about the Integrity of said
things which hey some of us do some of
us don't some of us are there for the
great trailers if you care cheap plug
the wandering Dutch does an awesome
industry
this year and it'll be about the
Integrity of the actual games nobody's
getting paid for it don't watch us
because don't watch us because King will
manipulated yeah and make sure god of
the wall Ragnarok is considered deals
about it I think I think what it's going
to determine is if the sponsors and
people gonna go on like if they stay
underground then he'll do it but if they
start you know sending those emails we
don't feel comfortable sponsoring this
year because Hogwarts Legacy is
nominated for games imagine it would be
bad if you're gonna nominated imagine if
the one whoa now so so yeah yes or no
will hop not and not no fan nomination
does Hogwarts Legacy I need y'all to ask
only on this pedal is it going to get a
nomination in any category that is panel
driven I say best absolutely absolutely
okay absolutely mom
ten toes down okay so for game of the
year I'm struggling
he's like you're like God relax
um
RPG of the year I can see it being
nominated because it's one of those
smaller categories that they could
glance over in in one of those in
between segments you know they just
quickly read it over and highlight it on
the screen so the awards are nominated
by the industry though so if the
industry and I was I don't know if
somebody could tell me how many reviews
Hogwarts has um compared to like other
games if like if the if the media at
large decided not to cover this game
then I think you have your answer at we
won't it won't get enough nominations
because the people that actually
reviewed it
are they're going to be drowned out by
the people that didn't like I know some
big Outlets that did not play the game
that took that stance they're not going
to be submitting this game regardless if
they're playing in the background they
didn't bring you coverage they've made
their stance very clear so Jeff is going
to be looking at that and if I somehow
it does get nominated then I think
they're going to be looking at well the
game awards we got 103 million people
watching last year right crazy numbers
and they want to they want to keep
building on that success and I think
this is where they're going to be
sitting there doing the the cost risk
analysis well
are you implying that this is this is
financially driven if it makes sense yes
yes because he keeley's not going to say
oh yo the the everyone submitted it for
game of the year but we just had six
sponsors drop out and now we can't
really afford to do as much maybe we
just leave that one off the list and
we'll go with number seven or whatever
that makes the list and remember this is
not 2001 where you can you have no
choice we're on the cusp of games of the
year potentially flooding of the Zone
they're very easily excuses to be made
that I just didn't make the cut
okay I'll let you get to finish your
bars off my voice I know we went long
and it's just your overall thoughts did
I get your points on the wire do you
think I'm sorry if I skip yeah yeah
everybody no not me sorry if I get your
bars off I'll let you edit it did you
always [__] solved sorry thanks
[Laughter]
it's the most popular continue
um
the wire thing yeah I think it's
I think to everybody's point it
it really
it shows that there is people are so
caught up with
and I'm saying it just I'm generalizing
and I'm sorry but certain outlets and
individuals at these Outlets are called
so caught up with
you know pushing social issues and and
projecting their social agendas onto the
platforms that they work on that they
they fail to understand that the fact of
the matter is that you don't have the
right to do that
um I don't know if you guys remember a
while back when you know IGN sort of
took a stand on the the Palestine Israel
conflict and you know they they was they
kind of they pulled down they they they
made us they made a statement stating
what side of the argument they they were
supporting and they put links in in a
letter indicating you know this is this
is how you can help uh Palestine and
immediately it got taken down and there
were meetings and stuff you know around
it and ultimately
it stayed down and it stayed down
because as an employee of a company you
don't have the right to project how you
feel
as that's what the company feels you
just don't you just don't
so it just when you when you see the
state of
of the industry in terms from from the
from the writing side
it's it's teetering it's teetering on
the edge of just on the brink of being
eliminated completely and these types of
actions I feel are so selfish
and they poison the pot all the way
around because they are and the fact of
the matter is that the old way of doing
media is just changing it has been
changing forever
and he said that there's just no way
around it if you don't change and you
don't adapt to what how people are
consuming gaming news and media you're
gonna you're gonna get eliminated
because a lot of these holding companies
that own these these Outlets if they
don't see the money coming in
you're gonna go no matter how popular
you think you are even IGN if IGN
doesn't stick to their SEO strategy
and stop getting the click that they get
you've already seen that they're loot
they lose staff right so they they're
not immune to that they may go if if for
whatever reason they don't do that so
the fact that you're self-sabotaging in
this way by putting out a review
that has nothing to do with the content
of what you're supposedly reviewing it's
just so far removed from what the ethics
of this should be that it's it it's
baffling to me because it's
self-sabotage you just want to go I
guess
In fairness I just want to push back so
I like what do you think
that outlet could do if they strongly
disagree with what Hogwarts represents
what do you think is the the correct way
of handling not review the game the same
but they can't separate that or the same
thing I I said when Ty was on
not one of these Outlets has take
they've taken the time to
curse JK Rowling to make blanket
statements of what she said or hasn't
said not one of them has put out
an essay a letter indicating everything
that that breaks down what she said and
why it's harmful in an objective manner
not a one so what happens is your
message just become just sounds like
you're like you're bullying like you're
trying to force your views on other
people without defending them you can't
put
you can you should not put thoughts out
there without receipts you just you have
to be able to defend your points
it's just the other I heard Colin say
this and he he surmised what I said when
Ty was on in a very in a very sort of
simple way and it's perfect he asked the
question
what did Hitler do
you can definitively say why Hitler is
the worst 100 you could a list of why
Hitler is one of the worst human beings
ever when you when you break down what
did JK Rowling do that makes her on that
level of one of the worst human beings
as some people will have you believe
that right well that that's the
messaging that some Outlets or
individuals are trying to push it's very
hard to do because a lot of what she
said is taken it's manipulated she may
she may feel a certain way about certain
things but it's just everybody's coming
at it from an angle everybody's coming
at it with an agenda I have not seen one
one Outlet say this is an an essay that
delineates all of these things that have
in the timeline of what she said and
done as objectively as possible so that
people can read it and make their own
minds up right
if you're an outlet and you do that
I can respect your stance on it and I
still respect again if an individual
writer says hey I recuse myself right
from reviewing this game because I feel
this way and I know I can't be unbiased
in that regard fantastic thank you that
is wonderful 100 respect that
let's move on when you say no I'm going
to rate this game not on the merits of
the game
on on what it subjectively represents to
me
and mind you reviews are subjective like
this it is the opinion yeah that's true
but when the opinion is not based on the
content of the game you lost already you
lost so so for me it just it poisons the
entire well of these other media
companies that are still trying to do
good work against this tide this
changing tide of what media is in the
gaming space and you're just it just
seems like you're you're you're really
hastening the demise of it all really
with this type of behavior that really
really bothers me and what was the other
thing in regards to this that we were
talking about we talked about what it
said and we talked about the the
nomination thing and I think you you
talked about that earlier whether yeah
the nomination thing it was another
thing we were talking about with the
with the wired article but anyway I
forgot but but it's just I don't know
man I just
it just it's so weird to me because it
just doesn't make a whole lot of sense
like this is your job and I understand
being able to be yourself and and and
and and and and feeling good about
having that freedom but you don't have
the right to do certain things and in
that regard it's just
if you ever want to be taken serious
throughout your entire career you have
to separate the two because otherwise if
you don't then then you're relegated to
being hired by people that just think
like you and if you run into a situation
if you run into a situation where
somebody is hiring you that does not
think like you or is removed from that
they're going to see what you've done
and see that you can't be objective and
that's going to work against you and it
just it just it's self-sabotaged in so
many ways and I just don't understand it
I don't understand it because we can be
true to ourselves in our private lives
but understand that again the gray area
in in our public lives it is very
difficult to live a life removed from
any type of hypocrisy because it's
guaranteed there's something that we
like or love that we're not going to let
go of that has some kind of nastiness
around it it's just what it is yeah my
final thought just there's always the
right way to to go about doing something
without imposing your view your personal
view or on someone to the point where
you want to you know do some type of
there's harm or threats and and again
there are many people I cross paths with
I don't agree with their political views
religious views what have you right but
I never let that come between let's have
a discussion and and really talk about
get to the core of the issue and we
still may agree to disagree but
respectfully you know and that's pretty
much all I got on it but appreciate
y'all taking bets on how much smoke
atomic heart gets
look you know like you said eloquently
you know it's becoming harder and harder
to uh to to be morally absolved from
everything and like I said whatever side
of the fence you're on it it's not
attack of anyone who says they are not
supporting the game I I understand that
again my only issue is you know the way
you go about trying to impose your view
on others that that that's all I'll I'll
leave it at that so yeah agree to
disagreement we can agree to disagree on
Crocs too brother yes you take those
Minecraft Crocs and you keep those over
there brother but I love you I still
love you you throw them straight in the
bushes but let's get this man
we got tons we got a ton and again I
know I got everybody here I don't know
anyone's on time delay you let me know
if you gotta bounce whatever yeah we
rocking so if you want to rock you feel
free to rock
shout out to KSI with the map with the
Mario three 33 years old today baby old
school baby had to go old school today
I'm sorry Super Mario I'm old as hell
that game is 33 wow that's crazy that's
crazy and I'm still peddling this on the
kids
as you should impose your views in that
right
shout out to Gene I can see Carl get
some 90s Crocs no you won't I like it oh
what happens if you if you knew for sure
if you wore those 900 Crocs they'd win
the Super bowl next year
these hypotheticals bro that's the
secret sauce
we're gonna move on we got drawn to draw
on TJ five dollars which at high Lords
High chat everyone please hit the like
button yeah we have over 500.
hit that like button man save some save
some rare animals in the country
somewhere by doing it I read that
already I'll listen to this tomorrow for
my work they keep with the great work
what animal are we saving today we did
the Platypus we said you'll say we gotta
save some of our dated species cake is
usually good with the animals
[Laughter]
it might be a little late for that one
hit the like button man let's go oh okay
hold on a second actually I've read some
things we got Lord roughness remember
for one year five pound Super Chat
picked up Hogwarts Legacy on Steam deck
it's RPG heaven I'm not even Harry
Potter fan absolutely loving it and I
think that's the overwhelming uh message
that I'm seeing at people that aren't
Potter fans are like it's a great RPG
and that's what I just love weird RPGs
and we have ducky five dollar Super Chat
beat Hogwarts A couple of days ago
that's Beastie damn a must play it got
me away from Destiny 2 for a bit wow
he's a Savage bro I love that yeah
that's one of the best in the class he
beat that game that fast
then we have Lord roughness again member
for one year two pound Super Chat
Hogwarts first hour will hook most
players yeah that the game starts out
rocking yeah some stuff happens yeah
then we have Rob the Don 202 two dollars
for time thanks for the entertainment
who did y'all logo oh
um dinero Panero is who took it to the
to the all Next Level and uh and it's in
conjunction with the late oh man oh from
TF of man tick my bad cow man recipes
now there's a collaboration between the
two we had we came up with the logo
itself
um shout out to Lord SWAT he came up
with the logo itself and then we gave it
to um Cal and then dinero Panero took it
to the next level so that's what you see
now
then we have Thai casares three three
dollar Super Chat what happened the
attic did he lose a bet to King I think
he's referring to the trench coach they
call him peacock they call him yeah you
know what's funny this is literally the
jacket I wear when I go outside people
sitting there yeah it's because you got
that and you got the fresh cut so it's
the like something they they they they
expected we were some like camo like
yeah like one piece yeah like you're
very distinguished today like you know
what I'm saying like I see I see what it
is yeah then we have Nintendo Taco
remember for what year five dollar Super
Chat Hogwarts dips frame rate I ain't
paying 60 for that I'm gonna save that
money for tears of the king
they come to Nintendo it would
definitely be different frames you mean
the abacus
shots flying then we have Paris like
heart boxes big franchises can perform
well HP film Harry Potter films have
made over well over 78 billion or 7
billion at the box office the books have
made billions the games the games will
will do as expected the games will do as
expected
no matter what you do that woman don't
need your money she don't need this this
money from this game she don't need no
money for the rest of her life yeah yeah
they've got Joshua two dollar Super Chat
ravenclaws unite how many ravenclaws did
a chat if it's a raven close-up actually
I'm gonna make a poll what what yeah put
the houses up put the houses up see who
wins let's put let's put some of the
names up yeah what what did you name
your characters say hello to cyberus
Black
sour is black dance Opera is black
yeah that's why I'm funny yeah we got a
flame member for two years five dollar
Super Chat gaming good afternoon IOP
Hogwarts Legacy earned its accolades and
Commercial Success great gains prevailed
now back to my octopath traveler 2 demo
Real Game of the Year dude come on dude
I was coming I knew he's gonna throw
that octo talk yeah
maybe we have Chris McComb five pound
Super Chat well said I'm not a Harry
Potter fan at all but respect to this
game and it's one of the best movie Time
games ever they nailed the the the core
of the franchise
and we got hargit Shani remember for 19
months Lord gold yes only controversy
with Hogwarts to talk about is the PS
exclusive content leaving players on
other platforms high and dry it's time
to bring this up with Congress all games
should be complete on all wait hold on
hold on what kind what content they got
they have uh
do this there is there is a like
exclusive like um like a shop bells and
shops and stuff like that there's a shop
there's there's a like a story Mission
with a specific shop
in uh Diagon Alley or something like
that it's not not a huge deal listen
after the Spider-Man Fiasco or whatever
yeah but I will say so the marketing is
from my understanding like they can't
even mention that is on other platforms
like already is treating this as if it's
an exclusive in a way as far as the
marketing rights it is very very strong
very strong shout out to Jim shout out
to Jim um
there we have Paris Lockhart once again
two lawsuit chat can't we all just get
along yes I wish it were that easy
brother some people it's just not then
we got Hector the Macho Man five dollar
Super Chat all hail the Lord's Hogwarts
did not win will not win game of the
year because of certain fan base with
exclusive votes and thoughts and prayers
for forespoken DOA oh slander I'm going
to buy for spoken on on sale and I'm
going to play that game at some point
okay
just finished Hi-Fi Rush played intro to
Hogwarts and oh my God it's awesome yeah
addict with these biased polls what is
going on Gryffindor no one likes them
Hufflepuff
Ravenclaw sells you Claus time to cancel
attic yeah Pro Slytherin want to root of
all it's like now he's trying to
influenced the check
good uh and oh my God it's awesome can't
wait to get into it great year so far
Zelda and Starfield still to come yeah
it is if if things drop the way they're
supposed to this year is out of control
it's already crazy yeah because even
even the side stuff is looking banging
crazy
Argy Geneva once again remember for one
year five dollar Super Chat Sony put
Hogwarts as one of their games at CES
yeah they obviously don't care about
controversy exclusive content marketing
Hogwarts custom dual sense yeah that's
right and that video that dual sense is
sold out out and he's right that's where
I saw that it was Jim Ryan CES Hogwarts
Legacy was next to what was the other
big exclusive they got coming like a
Spider-Man they were acting like it was
I was like I'll have to check out is it
coming back I forgot it it was so
strongly marketed to do that it's the
right business move right like it's
gonna get a party game though like you
treat it like it could only be played
here in a way the last time they did
that is when Destiny won yes that's
Destiny one level energy they believe in
that that game they they they the
marketing has been set up in such a way
that they cannot mention it on other
platforms when you see it that's when
Xbox had to take out the fragrance ass
yes yes yes
okay then we have Lord roughness
remember for one year five pounds to
protect
iron Lord boom Erica map and other
content creators are my go-to game
reviews thank you appreciate that man
did you see Erica she put her thumbnail
is her name was in the have you played
it on Twitter yeah for years I'm not
taking notice media companies have
school or whatever what media companies
have scored and it's that's a sad thing
because I would say the vast majority of
us got into this because of wanting to
work for the igns of the game spots or
whatever so it's just it's kind of sad
that that turn has been taken but
whatever
um hold on let me scroll back we've got
a couple of more we got David hot right
you with the 25 Super Chat thank you
thank you brother just wanted to
contribute a little for the Pax East
Fund thank you much appreciate it says
king is not here I'll say it for him why
don't you like him exactly yeah
listen the Lord's went out they the king
king definitely won and they were like
yo why don't you love me so if you go
chat in here you gotta be subscribed
that is
mind everyone describe me does not mean
you need to give us money you need to
give us money no I did exactly look the
the biggest reason we do it obviously is
because we've been getting a lot of spam
chats in there and it helps cut down on
that drastically because now they got to
sit around for a minute to do it and
everything yeah people will do it over
and over again but now that they have to
wait a certain amount of time they're
less likely you'd be surprised that the
trolls really like they don't want to go
through those things and all you hot for
the night.com because we know about you
yeah I know about you yeah
it is working and we get our two peeps
up your head and the Ralph's absolute
for y'all
Taco now it's time for the real topic
I know I know then we have masokista
five dollar Super Chat okay now let's
talk about how tears of the kingdom is
DLC oh very messy messy
we have oh let me see we got Mandingo
Mystic five dollar Super Chat Hufflepuff
Mitch's a character name
come on yeah I like that oh bro you
really taking your namesake to the next
level bro I see what you're doing look
man Ravenclaw winning by like three
percent oh yeah yeah
they all said listen I I changed it I
used I used to call all of my RPG
characters Jim [__]
time time moving on moving
wins the IOP cup did it finish already
did you finish the uh no no it's just
winning then we have Captain Chad's five
pound super chat here in the UK Sony
have four London uh buses painted for
each house Sony knows how to Market
great show guys I haven't seen if they
have uh that's because they they had I
mean they had they had Time Square
painted they had Grand Central when they
came to Ragnarok when it came to
remember yep
um that's crazy they're not playing
they're not playing that's crazy uh then
we have Paris Lockhart again
Hogwarts can win game of the year like
Eldon ring did people all over the world
are playing it if it keeps momentum it
will get multiple nominations that's
interesting bro I think you really have
faith in in in journalists would
survived
what if they want that would be crazy I
guarantee you if it's if it's in there
and it wins or you'll see people walking
out
um you're gonna see it you're gonna say
a political statement like you think
that there's gonna be a serious issue if
it get if it doesn't get a uh it doesn't
get nominated for anything and then
people are upset because it's gonna it's
gonna be a conversation around it for
sure we'll be talking about it yeah
Harris said it can survive that trip I
mean again outside of the bubble of
Twitter and the gaming sphere yes 100
but this these are the key leads these
aren't you know the worldwide game
awards it's not that yeah
let's play with each other two dollars
Jim what now song
Yeah Yeah someone
yeah so look you know I'll set it up
this was King's topic and um and he's
not here so we can move on
look we gotta talk about it man it
tender direct went down you know what
I'm saying there's a lot of information
that was uh put out there as far as the
releases and what's going on tears of
the Kingdom all that good stuff
obviously we got all Metro Prime
remastered you know Shadow drop February
8th boom you know what I'm saying so we
got that Pikmin 4 Game Boy and Game Boy
Advance games are available on switch
online Advanced Wars one and two boot
camp released that was for me on Mario
Kart 8 Deluxe boosted course pass wave
five a Splatoon 3 expansion pass Kirby's
Return to Dreamland uh Deluxe against a
new trailer demo Xenoblade Chronicles 3
expansion pass Fire Emblem engage Alex
gave new DLC you know what I mean story
DLC Disney illusion and then uh sea of
stars octopath traveler 2 demo available
Bayonetta Origins and they got a new uh
Gameplay trailer dead cells returned to
Castlevania man the list goes on there
was a ton of stuff in this uh direct and
some surprise releases and stuff like
that but uh yeah I want to talk about
that and then King one and two also talk
about so it looks like uh
Nintendo has entered the chat as far as
uh tears of the kingdom in the price
range and that has sparked a lot of
discussion initially some have said that
um yeah that this baby went off and
others may feel that hey this is the
distance
I think it's it's big first party
releases I think that's what it is
that's what it is so let's let's talk
about it man some of my kids move I
resonated
all right
wait for all these bomb new Nintendo
releases and sir
didn't you didn't you rage quits uh
Zelda the last Zelda absolutely
I still think breath of the wild is one
of the most overrated games
wow I don't understand it uh wow your
your stick has stamina like stuff like
that I was like oh okay
the I didn't get to watch the wreck I
think it happened just to give you guys
a heads up was it Thursday or Friday it
was Wednesday
it was during the attic show okay so
yeah so that means I was on my way to
work
um on my way from work so I didn't get
the uh watch it but I noticed no they
had some highlights took a page out of
Xbox book with the uh oh you know with
the stuff drop the Metroid Prime the
Xbox is the only two days Dave it was
clear they had a Stern release date for
that game
you know it worked for this you know
listen why not you know but yeah
I like how Xbox do one Shadows
nothing
nothing special kid that was very
disrespecting continue the attack razor
remake
I do appreciate though Nintendo for
doing the Metroid Prime actually I'm
contemplating uh utilizing my door to
switch
um to play honestly the Metro Prime uh
he's looking around his house
no I don't yeah I don't play it like but
like Metroid Prime was one of the games
I did buy for like GameCube
um long ago so I I am interested in
trying that out and and apparently from
what I'm hearing they did a good job
like people are saying how is this a
remaster this should be considered a
remake and for them to self-drop that
you know salute to Nintendo
um
the uh I did like I don't usually keep
up with Nintendo Direct so correct me if
I'm wrong was there a confirmation on
that uh tears the kingdom price oh yeah
yeah yes yes it was it was shown on
multiple retail sites it's it's 70. it's
seven seventy dollars let's go where are
we at how is it that Nintendo was
because every time we want to argue
sales Nintendo switch is a last-gen
console right
how is it
and they long start stopped doing
um Wii U switch cross releases right
that was like well actually I think
technically because Wii U ended so soon
switch would actually have this
generation console
um continues where are we going with the
seven dollars what are we doing I mean
it it's good Nintendo just voluntarily
like hey you know what seventy dollars
seventy dollars for a Nintendo game now
it's bad enough
don't have discounts are are pretty much
retail like whatever they launch at
that's their price for eternity their
games do not go on sale
the level of quality of their games they
refuse to break down the price kids the
level bro
this is hype alone hype alone there
Nintendo was bought to expose
how
what's the word I want to use without
being disrespected
the vulnerability of their fan base
to sell this game for seventy dollars
now we
know we implied the Tegra chip cannot
withstand The Fray rates of modern
gaming Nintendo could have got away with
this if they were lunch in like that 4K
switch Pro whatever they were supposed
to be doing that next year but they
literally just said you know what we're
just gonna give it to them hey why not
why not there's enough distractions
going on that they should just fly under
the radar as a accepted 70 product
um so yeah I'm just gonna sit back and
watch you know everybody sit there line
up tears the kingdom to one of the
best-selling games
um of all time at 70 and it's going to
work because it's Nintendo they can't do
no wrong
um but yeah it is going to expose a lot
of these Nintendo guys uh and I've like
I said we've seen reactions I'm just I'm
I'm just looking forward to this well
it's okay because you know this is game
it's like it's okay because this is Game
of the Year this is quality all breath
of the wild you know it's so it's still
selling to this
so are you implying that Nintendo based
on their hardware and where they are
that they don't have the right to charge
seventy dollars for their games and do
you think that this is a a tread that is
going to continue with first party
releases for Nintendo yeah you know I
here's the thing yeah Nintendo doesn't
have the legal rights
I'm still mad the fact that a single
joy-con costs 80 bucks
the thing is now
tried to do so this is the first time
they banged us over the head
when they did the Skyrim Port yes I was
like oh this is the Xbox the game so
y'all can holla at them about that yes
a quadruple a this is the game that you
guys bought a switch for this is this
warranted no Nintendo who does not
Nintendo's consoles everything Nintendo
does is overpriced
what was the last thing Nintendo sold at
a loss Michael they sold you cardboard
once
not the lava we can't get them for the
live boat come on
Nintendo sold
but kid but the argument could be made
that the market dictates you know what I
said what they sell it and people are
willing to pay Nintendo quality
operating in under inflation over 15
years now like the only thing I've ever
seen that they sold at a loss and it
took them a year to do it you know how
Nintendo they had the Mario Kart where
they had the real cars that were racing
yes yes yes I bought that for my kids
forever but before they were like you
need two switches for it right nobody
went for it Christmas is later one
switch is another one
I've ever seen them drop to fifty
percent okay
I'll let you finish your balls and then
we gotta get I gotta get Buffalo he's
been shaking his head even want to jump
in no I'm good I would I wouldn't hear
the rebuttals I want somebody to defend
this
some of it while we started direct you
know what I mean you know first of all
what standout titles were you anything
that you're excited about and then two
obviously the I call it controversy but
it seems that tears of the Kingdom
seventy dollars look like it's going to
be joining the ranks of the uh the other
two that uh I'll be the Xbox and Saudi
I've kind of now joined into the 70
first person first party releases yeah
so I'm living in the past I'm living my
best uh old generation Nintendo life
yeah all right we got we got Kirby's
Return to Dreamland box which is a Wii
games we got Tales of Symphonia
remastered this is a GameCube game we
got Mega Man Battle Network Collection
shout out Maddie oh that's his Joy oh he
he it Game Boy games we got botan kaitos
one and two GameCube games we're coming
with the game Nostalgia and I'll tell
you why I'll tell you why let's go
because nothing else on this list is
really speaking
there ain't nothing sea of stars a good
little indie game but everything they
showed us was DLC or they're just like
yo those games we announced 17 years ago
on the uh on the on the on the Wii we're
finally making those and bringing the
switch same power same resolution same
oh yes here we go and then we get uh we
get Zelda and I'm not I'm I'm actually
with with kid over here I don't I'm not
a Zelda guy I'm not uh
I like some old Zelda games like Ocarina
time ages of or like I like the old
Zelda this new Zelda where it's all open
world I I can't do it all right that
ain't for me oh man I don't know if I
could bring you back it's this it's the
shell of old sodas it is literally the
original vision for Zelda it is
literally what it is
one game and act like it represented all
of the other games
why are you acting like that's my fault
that ain't my fault
you see this rare rare tweet when they
were talking about uh nuts and bolts all
right tears of the Kingdom more like
Zelda nuts and bolts all right because
you got that making Vehicles energy
going on here okay
um but my brother's gonna kill me this
is like he thinks that's a while it's
like is the best game ever made so he's
right there he's like I'll pay more than
70. yeah
um so I'm I'm alone
a little different with the seventy
dollars I don't think it's I don't think
for the switch first party because we
have Pikmin 4 coming out and that's 60
all right so I don't think it's first
parties across the board I think this is
because we're good switch has clearly
coming to the end of its life cycle or
this direct kind of confirms that for me
with nothing but DLC Indies and uh just
updates on things that show I think we
get an announcement towards the end of
the year they don't really I don't think
they have much else coming out this year
to be be honest with you guys maybe
maybe the smaller games here and there
but it's very obvious to me that they're
winded down getting ready for a big
announcement and that seventy dollars is
because it's going to be a cross-gen
title with whatever their next time oh
you go like the poll question but
continue yeah so so whenever they
announce their next one like oh you can
play Tears of the kingdom and guess what
it doesn't run at 17 FPS anymore
a solid 30 at least we probably that's
about it's gonna aim for 60. so now
you're gonna get you're gonna hang out
in that 40 range that that is the only
reason I think they can put this at 70.
there is no justification if this is
locked to the switch at seventy dollars
it is an outrage there's no reason that
games would like running at 40 480p dock
what Bayonetta three is like resolution
is oh my or Dustin talking about on
sacred symbols I was like you know
what's going on
oh I I loved I actually like the new
Pokemon quite a bit even though there
was full of bugs it added to the charm
of it but the resolution
it's filmic yeah yeah you know it's cute
with the The Fray rate glitches in there
yo when I had all those sunflower
walking behind me and it was running at
a nice eight frames per second that's
what that's I knew Pokemon were bad I
had a time where I got in encounters the
Pokemon and they would be in the wall oh
man damn Hey sir buffer bat has spoken
though he looks like he's gonna be in on
that
but I'm sorry I'll finish that if you
need to get your bars off you had
anything no no I'm good I'm good I'm
good enough for me for everyone else but
I don't know what you all paying 70
worth I can't say with Super Mario three
shirt rapping
um what did you feel Nintendo directory
standouts and then obviously the
controversy the seven reality is a
kingdom
so you see me sitting here and proudly
rocking my Mario Brothers 3 t-shirts
I will rep that to the death uh I uh
anyone who has seen me on my first
appearance on ILP knows that I will be
taking no slander when we talk about the
greatest game ever made which is known
as Tetris which is Mexico also on
yes I will take no slander but I I too
unfortunately must stand on my square
and say well for me anyway and it might
be different for others I understand
that for me I feel like Nintendo has not
has stopped speaking to us for a long
time uh-huh right they've stopped like I
said this on on on shout out to him solo
I said this in his chat and he thought
it was absolutely slanderous can you
imagine Microsoft did the dev direct for
45 minutes like these guys did their
their direct for 45 minutes and a lot of
people like was just like my Microsoft
knocked out the part five game these
dudes like showed you how many games
without with the exception of the old
retro ones that you recall you got
nothing to reference it's like come on
you know but muffin man makes a good
point he makes a very good point breath
of the wild was a cross-gen release I
was one of the few Wii U heathens on the
Wii U I still have my Wii U back there
and then it came out on on on the next
gen right so I can see them threading
that needle again here but by and large
like yeah I watched the direct it didn't
speak to me too much yeah there are a
lot of games on there there were a lot
of games and I'm not I'm not down
playing the games right but let's let's
also be clear for about two three years
now every time I watch a direct I see 80
of them and I go okay Game Pass okay
Game Pass and that's the same here too
they don't say that but like most of
them have already been if you if you
read through them most of them have
already come out and said oh yeah
they'll be day one game pass as well
right it's just kind of like you're
watching a game pass catalog without it
being called game passes with the
exception of the first parties right so
there's that right so that's what it is
uh I for one was very excited to see
Metroid Prime uh remastered but but
before a specific reason oh you Haven
you even how dare you try to put that
more powerful I didn't even know it ran
on the on on the on it's always run at
60. it's always running 60. you know why
he ain't want to risk it
available I e-shop that thing and I've
dumped it to this guy there you go I
mean that I mean again that that's
probably listen that how are you playing
tears of the Kingdom
there we go now now that's the
conversation I want to have IOP without
me supporting this slanderous stuff that
I'm hearing continue
I have been playing breath of the Wild
on my on my baby for a while now it runs
beautifully it absolutely does not made
for that platform sir I was hoping I was
hoping I could get I could get a lord
King David's opinion I don't know
there's been that DLC talk for a while
now and he's already on the net right
now he's already on Twitter like this is
not Dia and I'm like
[Laughter]
you know it's very subjective
but but I will say I will say some use
the word DLC as a pejorative I do not
okay because I believe that a game like
blood and wine on for for for a Witcher
3 is DLC but better in every way shape
or form than the original base game so
it can be technically DLC and can
Elevate the property not to say it in
the pejorative fashion at all I got you
but I saw of of Tears of the Kingdom
look like it could run on this guy
because the original base game runs on
this guy so that's technically DLC to me
so to the point of playing it on paying
the seventy dollars for it if I am
successfully able to run it on my baby I
may be able to justify that point
otherwise heck no you are not expecting
me to pay seventy dollars for for an
abacus game
I'm sorry switch out here commentator
you ain't perform yeah
look my kids love it I will always hey
indoctrinations I will always say that
but this Hardware was outdated when it
was released okay I'm sorry for those
who don't know that's true the X1 chip
was created in 2015. yes right switch
came out in 2017 it was two years old
when it was first released and it's been
it's been dogged ever since it speaks to
the fact that people love Nintendo and
the developers really love Nintendo that
you seem to get impossible ports left
and right those impossible ports are
becoming like Mission Impossible
right damn I'm hoping that we do see new
hardware right yes give me at least
Hardware that matches this guy and I'll
be there right
as it stands right now I'm like it's not
for me you know I I saw a lot of the the
first the the big drops I know lots of
people gonna love it I'm I'm there for
you I appreciate it I will stand with
you I will play the monochrome Tetris
for a while every once in a while I will
appreciate that but yeah don't come at
me with 70 expect me to play it on the
Abacus himself oh damn okay all right
I thought you might be hype about this
got a lot of good game releases and then
that tears of the Kingdom 70 and we good
right what's up
uh as far as the directive wasn't for me
uh the majority of the games they didn't
really appeal to me whatsoever damn you
know I they're like oh we're gonna show
you Super Nintendo emulation and uh then
we're gonna show you this and that I'm
like I don't care about none of that and
and then when you see Zelda they're just
pretty much like look we know this is
what you think the game's looking like
we're here to tell you this is what the
game looks like
so I mean it's cool uh I do feel like it
was over hyped I saw people on their
same best direct ever there was like
five different directs that I enjoyed
more than this I don't maybe we were
watching different things you know I
don't know what was going on there but
you know I'm not seeing the same
difference between other people if you
like that direct do you do I don't care
respect
um I just when it comes to like the
the switch I do think it we need to
upgrade because
I've reviewed a few switch games in the
past six months and every one of them
ran bad and it wasn't like one or not
two Fire Emblem had a lot of uh a lot of
screen tearing some of the worst screen
tearing I've ever seen in a video really
wow and you know sure did the game Run
better than Pokemon yeah but what's that
really saying not much yeah it's it's
just like it felt like after about two
three years because it for a while it
was every game runs horrible on the
switch but Nintendo games yeah and now
we've gotten to the point where every
game runs horrible including Nintendo
games like yeah Forte coming for you
said attic with sleep during the show he
said you were sleeping really dead well
yeah because they didn't do nothing to
wake me up
that's that was the best NyQuil ever man
if I had insomnia problems ever again
I'ma put on that's Direct on the TV
while I'm trying to go to sleep but you
know I I like the prime I do think I
want to try that because I played it a
long time ago I don't remember nothing
about it but it's just like there's so
much stuff out right now it's just I I
don't really got time for that like I do
like how it was forty dollars because I
thought they could have tried to get 70.
it would not have surprised me you know
Zelda going up ten dollars it's just
like it was for for a PlayStation and
Xbox you know at least PlayStation and
Xbox were like we're only gonna get that
for next-gen stuff for current gen at
this point you know if you want an Xbox
series X or a PS5 game you're paying a
seventy dollars uh but Nintendo's like
we're gonna charge you 70.
for the same game
system that we had five years ago seven
years ago whenever it came out I think
2017 is when it came out it's just it's
it's funny but at the end of the day
what are we gonna do we're just not
gonna buy Zelda
um
one one last Quick
to that please I want you to go and give
as much as much smoke to Mr ever born
Saga as you can yeah
Mr charged them more Mr got a t-shirt
but as soon as Zelda comes out and I say
70 he's like charged me more I don't
know how it is
and as far as like the emulation thing I
think I'm more upset with the emulation
stuck behind the subscription service
than anything because to me that's the
reason that they sold the Mario game for
x amount of time because they they
wanted to bring value on the N64 Mario
game Mario 64 that was put behind their
subscription service and to me it's like
I'd rather just buy them individually
like I just I don't like this thing
where we're starting to put emulations
behind uh behind subscription Services
because if you know what's going to
happen if they make the switch too if
it's not backwards compatible are they
going to want us to do that again like
it's just there's just so don't buy
digital Nintendo games that's why I do
not trust them to respect my digital
purchases not like PlayStation and Xbox
interesting interesting and to be honest
with you you have the the right thought
process on that because you know
remember when Poco the old Pokemon games
were worth over like 200 each like it's
just like at at the end of the day I
don't I don't agree with the 70 I I
don't I think they bugging with that but
what am I gonna do I'm gonna not play
Zelda okay that's not happening like I'm
not gonna flip out over ten dollars yet
now yo but I could still
play the game respect the game but still
[__]
I don't I don't co-sign it
but there ain't nothing I could do about
it so I'ma still commit you know I I can
still support and complain and I'm gonna
do it
complain while you're down there fair
enough
so thoughts so uh the directed um
seventy dollars tears of the Kingdom me
yeah I mean like
if you're a gamer who who equates money
spent on the amount of you know with the
amount of time you're gonna spend with a
game so many dollars for this game
it seems like a bargain right 100 like
if that's what you equate you know value
to uh this game is going to be hundreds
of hours long if you really invested
time into it that's just what it is so
so that's that
now optically is it horrible yes
horrible it's horrible because it's just
like it's them telling you and we we
said this before of The Big Three
Nintendo really is the worst in terms of
like they hate you why they hate you
what's going on
not only do they hate you they laugh at
your face they hate you they're like you
ain't they don't do nothing buy your
game and shut up like when you you talk
about like you know
it is really Nintendo Nintendo's really
setting their ways and you're gonna
either Xbox since Xbox and Playstation
dive on it they put like a toll in it
Nintendo jumps in the pool every year
they know right they know like they know
what we've always known it's just that
they're in their own lane and what they
figured out this generation is that they
have no business trying to be in the
same Lane this place places in Xbox they
just don't so now they've reestablished
their own lane and they're not they
don't need to deviate from it and they
they you know they pick and choose what
they want to dabble with oh yeah 70
bucks they go pay that for Zelda no
question they're gonna pay that they're
not worried one bit that you're gonna
pay Seven dollars
they're not worried about the optic
season they don't care
um so whatever man it's just them
jumping on the bandwagon but it is kind
of funky when you you know five years
six years in into this console that like
the chaos office point was I already
outdated when it launched
it was fun
it would be different if Zelda flocked
but we know it's definitely not going to
go that way like they're gonna charge an
extra 10 bucks and they're gonna laugh
straight to the bank and I and I agree
with the Muffin Man that I do think I
don't think it is the final game that is
going to be it no I do think it's going
to it's going to be a cross gen game
that will make a version of this for
whenever the next console is
um but I think it's going to be you know
they're due for a Mario game either a 2d
or 3D Mario so it's so they do for Mario
game we could easily see that at
whatever you know summer presentation
they have and have it launched in the
fall just like 2017 right because they
don't be interesting so if they get the
if they go ahead and upgrade
and then they're like you know we're
going to let you keep all your other
stuff like do you guys think that when
Nintendo does eventually upgrade they're
going to live be backwards compatible or
you think they're just a question I
think they will I think the next thing
okay
caveat this thing and I have talked
about this Nintendo don't care so they
may well be like oh we just got to do
something different right they're
they're toy makers they're toy makers
they're tinkerers they like to innovate
at the same time a lot of that is
changing you see Mia model sort of
stepping aside you see The Changing of
the Guard she Bowser up front right uh
it kind of feels like that's a decision
I would see I could see Reggie making
like no we believe in Generations the
next thing is going to be different
um
I don't know that new Nintendo
necessarily thinks that way so I'm not
sure they could very well give us
something that looks nothing like the
switch uh whatever it is I do think it's
going to be hybrid they're going to stay
hybrid okay but I don't know I don't
trust them that's sorry
so I got a question that you saw
do you think the reason they've waited
so long to make a a a new switch is
because they saw the uh the trajectory
and they saw the possibility of
overthrowing the PS4 as far as like
sales and maybe they can hit that PS2
and that's the reason they're taking so
long I don't know having the most sold
conso ever in history is a pretty nice
Flex that's a nice flex but I mean what
does it matter in the long term I think
they they got caught between a rock and
a hard place when they couldn't you know
with the pandemic they couldn't get all
the parts they needed to make the
whatever the the switch Plus or whatever
they were going to call it so they just
went with okay let's put the OLED screen
you know let's give them the new battery
whatever and that'll be that so they
couldn't they just couldn't make it it
they couldn't justify doing it when they
wanted to do it so they just skipped
over it completely and they said okay
we'll just give them an upgraded screen
understand the other but the switch Pro
was supposed to be the OLED with a
little bit but whatever more power or
whatever and it just didn't it didn't
materialize so they decided to just you
know omit it completely and move forward
so I mean that's a nice flex but you
know I think on inertia alone I think
the switch will
will get there
uh you know Zelda's gonna sell consoles
oh yeah
uh Mario's gonna sell clothes we're
gonna see what the fbd do yeah I'm gonna
name the next switch switch you yeah
like like 40 million away from from PS2
and DS that's why I honestly feel like
that's the reason they're doing it
because they they went through a lot of
generations where they weren't exactly
on top and now that they're on top
they're like we start to that top
position and no one go mess with it
because to me they've won so long
there's no reason how many iterations of
the 3DS do they go through
they they are not shy from cutting and
moving on but for this generation for
some reason feels like it's lingering
way too long and to me there's an
objective behind that I mean well to me
to me it comes the way I see it I don't
think the objective is the best-selling
console was I think it is the first time
that they've ever they've eliminated
scared to move on too well this is the
thing right they eliminate it completely
eliminated their mobile vertical it's
not mobile anymore it's all one thing
right so it's not like they're moving on
from the 3DS from a handheld purely
handheld and sticking with the console
and moving the console forward it all of
it is encompassed in one machine right
so
they don't necessarily if if it
continues to sell well the numbers are
still there yeah they are they coming
down some yes are they the sales still
crazy yes so because their ecosystem is
in one under one box now
it doesn't behoove them to move forward
quickly if they know it's still selling
I will say but not to mention they're
out selling New Gen Hardware the PS5 the
Xbox series consoles they're out selling
them with 2017 but this is the first
time we're starting to see signs of
slippage this is the first time as far
as it shows
but the last quarter like they even
themselves come out and said that it was
disappointing for them okay it's
obviously you want to jump is okay yeah
and and um unfortunately I must I must
depart
I will I will rebut one thing you said
this off there's one piece of the puzzle
that it has been reported but it's very
techy and most people don't pay
attention to it even Nvidia is kind of
like come on man
new technology that's overshadowing the
Tegra X1 you're the only one that wants
to keeps ordering it to the point where
they're actually charging them more it's
like it's like asking you're asking your
Best Buy for a cassette player in 1023
200 per you know yeah they're still
asking for it so even the manufacturers
like come on man let's move forward move
forward yeah and Nintendo had to cut
their um their Hardware Sales
expectation because they they themselves
said the switch did not perform as
expected during the holiday this season
so you know they they brought their
forecast down from my understanding good
at it yeah
I want to go around right now and before
uh assati you start because you're about
to leave when do we see a switch
successor
oh I think we like because they will
they Nintendo will speak again before
the end of this year I think the next
time they speak their next big kind of
Showcase of any kind I'm not talking
about like a simple direct but a good
one before the end of 2023 ends you at
least hear about it at least you hear
about it you know as muffin man is
suggesting they may not release it this
year but you'll at least hear about it
this year they'll at least start that
thing talking you'll hear about the
switch you or the Superstar
I love that one
about that towards the time that they're
gonna hey what crazier things have
happened maybe we see it this this
Christmas I doubt that yeah I highly
doubt that I can see I could definitely
see I don't they haven't really done
this but I could see a a achilles
revealed oh I could see a kid these
words real time frame absolutely
absolutely so how well that works for
Microsoft so maybe reveal 2023 2024 for
for Holiday 2024.
um exactly now the question is to add on
the addicts question is do we think it's
a revision or an upgrade to the current
model or do we think to soft point that
they are the toy makers they are known
to create the wheel sometimes that's
where I don't I don't even trust myself
standing I just don't know man because
they again to me I do think it is a
hybrid thing is it smart business to to
include the Swiss library in this a
hundred percent have they always been
known for making smart businesses no
they've been known to come to you know
made a whole new paradigm
everything that the next one most likely
will just be all digital whoa could be
whoa it could be no no no no they I
don't know they make a lot of money
though they make a lot on cartridges
physical physical yeah buffer box you
think what's your prediction of of
potential announcement of a new whether
it be an upgrade or a whole new console
uh announced this year released next
year oh be ready it has to the switch is
barely hanging on here folks
we say that but see that's that see
that's nice
but that's the thing only only people
like us care about the performance this
is why this is why my my second half the
prediction is whatever the next one is
they would be stupid to get rid of the
switch like the format yeah it's it's
Gotta Stay this switch hybrid like
whether they call it a super switch like
keep it in the family and then they're
like it still counts like we're just
gonna keep raising that number sale
it also has to be backwards compatible
okay the outrage
what if they hit you with the lady and
stay down this is this is
you got it you got to get it is it a
kingdom seventy dollars again
you want me to play you want me to pay
10 20 more you gotta buy all this over
again but we got all the Fidelity you
want I think we out of throwing it away
I think the the next console isn't gonna
have switch in the name because I think
they're going to be concerned that the
Wii U Fiasco is going to have a again I
think in their Market they're gonna be
very upfront this is a new Switch hybrid
because it's just going to be like the
switch but it's switched backwards
compatible everything for the switch
carries over because I think they're not
going to want to go into that kind of
stigma and risk something happening with
the Wii U where people think it's an
accessory I I think it's going to be a
new console well hybrid and I do think
it's going to be uh combat backwards
compatible switch because they're going
to want to make sure that they're giving
no one they're going to release you like
the next Mario or something and they're
gonna be like but you could play
everything on this platform and I and I
bet you it comes with some kind of
trophy support whoa
[Music]
relax relax
to my friends maybe like a party chat
we're ready relax
I think they stick to the switch moniker
because the thing is by the time by the
time the Wii U came around the Wii by
that time was kind of a joke and it was
kind of dead it wasn't selling like it
had that big rush and it so it was like
the way it was the way it was marketed
it was just completely messed up because
it had really lost its steam by the time
the Wii U came out so people were like
it's more of the same right with the
switch I think the transition is going
to be super smooth because it is so
strong
here's the thing though we're coming off
the Wii to the Wii U probably one of the
most dominant they've ever had he was
dominant and they still dropped the ball
in terms of people getting this
messaging I don't think they're gonna
risk that but by the time the time that
we you came out the switch name was a
joke that's it definitely but we're
still off of like one of the most dummy
sorry the Wii names in history still
went to that yeah they dropped my
mindset is like I don't think Nintendo
is gonna let's be right here at the
switch at the switch successor isn't
successful
I don't know if Nintendo's gonna be able
to Captivate that again for a long time
right it took what three four
generations to get you back hogged yeah
no no this is I'm jumping real quick
because I get my balls off and I know
we're going along um look
as far as the direct
um you know great direct for them I'm
kind of in the pocket not a lot of stuff
for me which is more so Advanced Wars
but I'm a huge Advanced Wars guys and I
had spoke to my soul buffer but I don't
know if you you got that with that one
but that's turn based that's that's our
joint
um so that was for me I'm gonna pick
that up Metroid Metroid was a great
stealth drop love that pick it
definitely already started to download
on that and um yeah you know the
emulation stuff I get a chance to you
know to play they've got the format that
I've always wanted it we got to be
respectful you know this is my greatest
I'mma say a kid but this is my greatest
draft pick was predicting the success of
the switch I told people that's gonna
work I said people laugh me out the room
I was like I'm telling y'all because I
do one I'm that guy the guy that docked
at home and then I'll take it and I can
go on the goal and it becomes this
hybrid situation and I felt they felt
they found you know lightning in a
bottle and I felt it was what the Vita
should have been you know on the head
then they had the the form factor the
double you know the double shift buttons
the Dual analogs the pressing into the
analogs they they nailed it they've got
modern sensibilities as far as the
controller and and how it performs at
that time now granted okay that's at
this point we know the Tegra you know at
its top but it was punching above its
weight playing the 360 like titles you
know and seeing 60 frames on anything on
a Nintendo thing at a time it was fine
bro I was like oh I got 60 frames like
so they they pushed it as far as they
could go we're starting to see the signs
though we start to see the age now we
start to see okay you know it's really
doing the Lord's work trying to put any
port on this thing you know what I'm
saying the fact that developers are even
trying to put Witcher 3 you know and all
these things on it is is impressive but
it shows you that the market the install
base was so dominant it's stupid for you
not to do it but it's getting now too
cumbersome too much of an ask the Tegra
has really shown his age and now for the
first time they've been dominating NPD
killing it but you're starting to say
okay they're not winning it now you know
I'm saying here comes PS5 right PS5 now
is outside there's they have solved
their constraint units for the most part
you know so now it's like okay what are
you doing they're in a weird spot
because yes I'm with you solve one tears
of the Kingdom drop and not it's gonna
do what it do but overall if you look at
that forecast it's kind of we feel like
we're at the end it feels like it feels
like I don't know if there's anything
major that they could do and then like
you said I think both of mine you start
or whoever said that you're starting to
see the first party
stuff now starting to show its age
usually it was like okay the third party
stuff we get that but the first party
stuff you like yo what's going on so
yeah they're in a tough spot in the
sense of when to actually make the
switch I think I'm with addict though I
think they'd be they've found lightning
in a bottle with this format this naming
this branding to me it would behoove
them to keep the format I don't if they
jump out the window in Old School
Nintendo fashion and you know reinvent
the wheel
I don't know man cause if you don't nail
that and it's right it's so you could be
out of the industry
if you don't know like so they got to be
careful the Wii U is a prime example of
where it could go left so to me you
stick sweat you stick switch you stick
safe you you you you you go with your
partner's Integra and say okay here's
the the latest in video or whatever it
is and you stay in that format and you
upgrade your your Wi-Fi we know they're
playing nice with Xbox yo you know
azure's here you know if you want to
play nice you know what I'm saying game
passes here if you want to play nice and
then you know okay another thing that
we're not really taking into
consideration I might clown on them a
lot but
if I would be very surprised if
you know Gavin Steven over there wasn't
looking at the stream deck as like a a
pretty good success and they're like
wives if we make Steam games that are
designed to play on stream uh on the
stream deck and you know you might start
seeing more games that are designed
solely to play on the stream Wise from
the actual steam developers uh because
you know I think in a long time that's
the only piece of Hardware I could see
to even remotely compete with the switch
Yeah I mean and maybe they do stuff to
to make it more appealing because I
think that's one of the only things
that's hurting it is it can't compete
with the Nintendo games that were
designed to be played on the go the
thing that they've been getting away
with it is like soft said their
demographic let's be honest we're the
hardcore the Democrats don't care they
don't really care about that Fidelity
stuff that we care about as long as they
can play their beloved franchises you
know they're mostly good and like I said
when listen when May 12th big link come
outside it's going to be different
everybody better be clear it's going to
be different big link come out let's
move your release date I don't know why
I feel like saying pause every time you
say that
if big link don't come out and and the
game if the game's busted and it doesn't
run that good they ain't gonna care no
no but they cared on the Pokemon I got a
couple people that cared about that what
the sales numbers look at the sales or
the Pokemon
it might not hurt it might not hurt
Pokemon because people already bought
the game but if they start releasing
title after title and it barely runs and
it's crashing all the time that carries
over from title to title listen man
Nintendo said Pokemon Violet there's
18.2 billion into seven weeks the
fastest start of any title for a
Nintendo dedicated but it's also one of
the worst rated Pokemon games in history
they laugh right to the bank with the
ratings they laugh right
okay do your thing brother you wrap it
up appreciate y'all take care brother
thank you okay where can the people find
you brother still be listening yeah you
can find me in the slanderous one
everyone Saga we we host the gaming
Circle podcast Saturdays 10 a.m Eastern
Standard Time follow me on Twitter
you'll get all that when Twitter Works
absolutely pleasure brother that's
pretty much what I had on the Nintendo
topic anybody else gonna rap out and let
me know it's cool and then we'll just
finish up with the uh yeah I gotta I
gotta bounce too no doubt but if it's
the muffin man telling people say the
games media where can they find you what
you got going on man yeah thanks for the
invite guys I always love hanging out
with you but uh everyone that wants to
you can uh follow me at the muffin man
on Twitter 107 IO and seven a oh you can
come follow us at save game media over
on Twitter but you can go to our YouTube
to save the game media we're print out
podcasts like every single day I'm over
there on Project X talk and Xbox podcast
so if you want to come rock with me but
we got a whole network of people putting
out great podcasts and we're aiming for
a thousand subscribers oh let's get it
let's get them let's get them
always love hanging out with you guys
thanks everyone I'll chat you've been
great I'll see you no doubt I'll put the
links in the description make sure y'all
support the memes you know what I mean
we're gonna put that right now the
muffin mine up in there no doubt go
check that out that's the channel I mean
that's Twitter and then we'll put the
channel and all that good stuff man and
of course um ksanti as well we'll take
care if you can put that in there as
well too we can all take care of the
boys okay uh smooth how you doing I just
want to make sure I respected in your
tongues I know we do that one more topic
how you do it on you got a boogie where
you at
uh what's the last topic last topic is
MLB the show and the uh what you call
League stuff I I can stick around for
that no doubt no doubt so we got that
soft yeah you get the super chats real
quick we got
uh Nintendo on yeah
talk about the Nintendo numbers too yes
we did thank you
Nintendo get two dollars for chat change
of the kingdom is the only game worth
seventy dollars and that's facts
then we got Carl Andrews Junior five
dollars to protect get smooth out of
here with that breath of the wild
overrated day one Zelda fan Ocarina of
Time a classic not feeling this fools
responses
they do
he said they could just keep exposing
their uh their vulnerabilities
then we got Brian East five dollar Super
Chat wait for when the Nintendo's
next-gen system comes out and you have
to rebuy tears of the Kingdom for
another 70 with no backrest
compatibility that would be wild this is
the fear not reading the room or not
caring to read the rule
and we got the Nintendo ambio Taco again
five dollars I'm a hypocrite tears of
the kingdom is worth seventy dollars God
of War Ragnarok isn't it wow I'll be
there day one but I ain't paying seventy
dollars though oh yours is only 50. yeah
so the Nintendo has a thing with a
voucher program that you can buy first
party games
um and it's like yeah for a hundred
bucks you've got two vouchers and that
allows you to buy certain games at a
discount that are normally MSRP 70 bucks
now right
um so yeah even if game you know 60
dollar game same thing you would it'll
it'll come up to like 50. but I didn't
see tears of the Kingdom available to
buy through vouchers I'm not sure if
that's coming that's funny that that's
their term of sell you know give us 100
bucks we'll give you like
exactly that's how we'll do it exactly
so we have Carl Andrews Junior 2010
Zelda and overrated don't go together
and
um I don't like how close this poll is
uh so I'm ending this poll now
55 minutes
then we have uh THX 11 38 two dollars at
Metroid Prime and Zelda 160 FPS on Steam
that yes they do with Metroid Prime run
60fps on the switch that game is always
160.
he out of pocket anyway he completed the
poll oh my God
the poll was up for an hour it had 55
minutes left
then we got heartbeat today five dollars
to protect that before one year not just
to find the seventy dollars for tears of
the Kingdom we're pointing out switch
uses physical carts it's why they don't
discount much tears of the Kingdom could
need larger size costing more they did
say already tears of the Kingdom will be
the biggest Nintendo game to date on the
switch day it's almost 19 gigs oh damn
so
yeah uh we got black Ronin three five
seven five dollar Super Chat seventy
dollars ain't killing me when I already
buy Deluxe and Collector's Editions but
in Zelda's case it's agree disagree on
Nintendo Goldbergs go Philly affiliate
the building okay okay there we got
Nintendo Taco once again five dollars
which I'ma need y'all to bring me on
since y'all never get any real Nintendo
fans on the panel I'm tired of the bias
salute to the dog I respect that I
respected then we got myself five
dollars Super Chat seventy dollars for
DLC that runs at 480p and 10 FPS yikes
then we have glass hole games for Chad
glass hole okay 60 in 2017 is about
72.76 today after inflation so tears of
the kingdom is around the same price so
why 70 such a big deal
um it's perception it's Optics yeah
easily Nintendo showing they're not
immune exactly we got Lord Metroid here
I think that's what it is
yep okay Lord Metroid
with the five dollars Super Chat Zelda
is one of the greatest series in the
history of the medium tears of the
Kingdom will be game of the year and
another milestone for Nintendo be salty
all you want just facts it's gonna be in
the mix we got we can't front though
it's going to be in the mix you know how
it's how to do when they come so we'll
see yeah that's it we're caught up Gene
points out that WWF no mercy was 75
dollars
wow wow MLB the Show solve a lot going
on man what's up yeah man so MLB the
Show uh had his first sort of feature
Premiere they do this in the in the sort
of lead up to the launch of the game
every year where they kind of have these
breakdown videos with all the new
features coming to the game whether it
be modes or like additional animations
or they talk about all the changes they
make in this crazy nine month turnaround
time that they have every single year to
get this game out um and this year
they're going with something called
story lines the Negro Leagues and it's
kind of mimicking a little bit of what
you see in 2K with the my player stuff
in 2K the story mode stuff you see in 2K
you've seen it in Madden as well you
know story mode sort of stuff
um and this is going to be about the
Negro League so basically they they have
uh I think about um close to 10 uh Negro
League stars that you can pick from and
you can basically play uh sort of
instanced moments throughout their
career like important moments throughout
their career
um which sort of story background stuff
and like sort of documentary style
background stuff around it and they did
they've done this sort of stuff before
uh with just Legends of the game where
you can play important moments in that
history you know like Babe Ruth calling
a shot stuff like that
um but this is important the fact that
they finally have been able to get the
Negro Leagues in here um I'm a lifelong
baseball fan and for me
I I I was lucky that my dad taught me
about the history of the game and
growing up and and what it meant and
what I learned right I was my dad was a
big Roberto Clemente fan and so Roberto
Clemente was was King but what you
learned about historically about the
game is that the the the the Latino
story throughout baseball is very much
intrinsically tied to the Negro Leagues
um because that the Negro Leagues was
where you know again all minorities of
all kinds were sort of given the
opportunity to be able to play baseball
professionally and Negro Leagues was was
was around for 40 years from 1920 to
1960 and uh it's important that when we
look at how kids consume information
today the chances that you'll get young
players of of this game or young players
of baseball in general to kind of know
the stories of the history of baseball
and of the Negro Leagues through any
other way other than social media some
sort of medium online it's it's Slimmer
that it was when I was growing up right
so to have this as sort of an
educational tool I see it as in in this
game is super important where you can go
in and play this sort of story mode and
you can see the Highlight moments of
players like Satchel Paige and Jackie
Robinson Hank Thompson um and then back
to the Latino portion of it when you see
Martin de he go in there he go he's
Cuban like to me that was so
heartwarming to see that finally you
know this MLB the show was one of the
greatest simulations of of sport we've
seen in video games period just so
happens to be the only real simulation
yes out right now
um
but the fact that they're taking these
steps when I watch this sort of
presentation I saw the emotion on uh
Ramon Russell's face to talk about it
you know yeah to talk about it with uh
with BoB Kendrick who's the president of
the the legal league like great
interview highly recommend people
amazing amazing and Ramon has been at
the Forefront of of MLB the show and
interfacing with the community and from
for many many years and I I it shows
that this is something he was working
towards right
um so to me again
the opportunity to be able to experience
moments in these Legends lives and to
get the story behind The Negro Leagues
and how they came about and and and just
how important they are to the story of
baseball and and the story of America in
a lot of ways they call it baseball may
not be the American Pastime it once was
it's lost a lot of that luster
but what happened is baseball is so
integral to to to the American story
period
um it is it's important that that it's
handled in a way that is respectful and
shows reverence and I think this is a
beautiful step in that direction and
again as a Latino and and someone who
who reveres the the Latino aspect of
this the fact that it's recognized that
this is also part of the Latino Journey
um through the Negro Leagues it is an
amazing thing so that that's my take on
that aspect of it obviously we have the
the cover athlete Jazz Chisholm from the
um from the Marlins he's gonna be
playing center field this year he was
hurt last year
um that's obviously he he's a player
from the Bahamas he learned to play
baseball from his grandmother like it's
an amazing story
um uh obviously and it goes hand in hand
with what they're trying to do here with
with you know promoting the New York
leagues and having a player of color on
on the on the cover this year um I'm
super excited to see what this is you
know I get the show every single year A
lot of times I can't wait and I and I
pay that earlier
we're actually going to be a Paxman that
launches
so um yeah I'm excited for this
um I would I wish and obviously the
Derek jet I was just about to say You
Yankee fan Jesus
I love Derek Jeter I I nah I mean well
depending if that's the one that gets it
to you early I love Derek Jeter I love
Derek Jeter I'm gonna be honest though
I'm a little
I kind of feel like Maris needed his
moment uh okay you know I I know Aaron
judge has had a cover already so it'd be
kind of crazy to put him on again but
something very Maris focused that record
stood for a whole lot of years and for
for it to be somebody like judge to
break it another Yankee
um and again in my view it is it is a
true home run record in baseball
yeah not not so controversial
[Music]
unlike other situations
you know certain people who have not
gotten into the Hall of Fame stay where
you are oh that's your fault okay okay I
guess Barry can't make it
the thing is you know what Barry with
before the juice Barry's numbers are
good enough he was a beast before so
again I I don't not necessarily be mad
at that because he that's how good he
was that he was he earned it before he
started juicing uh you know but
everything else afterwards nah man okay
this is focus okay I got it kids move
you know MLB the Show uh the other title
looks like also Game Pass again looks
like the Microsoft deal continues uh
with the MLB and on multiple multiple
platform switch and all that but uh
Negro Leagues in any interest in this
year specifically for you
um my interest for like MLB the show is
pretty much consistent you know I I know
I'm going to dive into it play a couple
games try to get my one little cheap win
before I quit it
before the pros get in there yeah that's
what happened with the last year's games
like I got my couple wins I was like I
had them out
I'm happy to see that there you know
with the uh the Negro Leagues I get I
have um like my my aunt and my uncle who
are like a lot of my cousins they're
like Baseball fans so I did a lot of
like my historical stuff like through
baseball through them whether it was
going to like the Baseball Hall of Fame
and like like Cooperstown nice uh going
to different like um games and stuff
because I don't appreciate the sport is
obviously as much as other sports like
basketball and um football but it's um
I do have my my lineage and that's like
the like when we go when it's time to
like talk to like my cousins and my eyes
and stuff like that I I can like
piggyback I can refer to like hey you
get MLB the show I like or like and we
talk about things and they can like
speak to oh yeah yeah hey did you
understand that they're doing this with
this game they're adding this person
this person's on the cover uh they got
the um
the Negro League thing which is which is
a big deal and I'm happy that they're
um uh doing that
um so I mean I have no like smoke uh for
MLB the Show especially if you know
since it's you know I've made this
transition to Xbox and uh uh
I knew that was coming but but yeah like
I'm not like like obviously like um so
even like at this point I got my
favorite team obviously the Boston Red
Sox but like I said I can I enjoy like
baseball games just uh I can go to it
live it's the only thing in sport I
can't watch on TV but I can watch it
yeah watch it live yeah yeah I can like
it I can be there and experience it but
I can't watch it on TV unless it's the
playoffs
um but the video game though is for like
like long as nobody do nothing technical
like where they they mastered the
pitching game and mastered where to hit
the ball and we all could play on that
at a basic place
well I have a shot
but most people know the tricks and
stuff like that I'm like ah yeah you you
too good yeah you gotta get up early
with the game first before release okay
now I feel you I'm not an addict uh
Sports Aficionado the person who runs
out and gets all the questions
you know this is what he does so uh yeah
MLB the show and negro really interested
this year you know your sports couldn't
care less about MLB the show I like that
they're you know doing more on the the
history of MLB and you know the uh the
roots to it that's cool for the people
that actually care about the show uh you
you couldn't
I couldn't the thing I just I couldn't
find a truth not even a little bit that
that that's just been on game past the
past two years and I ain't downloading
not even fired up and even ain't even
wasting the download speed how long do
you think this this deal is for it's
gonna be a minimum of five years right
one with dick right this this is
continuing yeah it just it feels like
it's a minimum five years but I know it
felt it could have been like a tenor
like yeah I mean look we got to say this
MLB clearly loves this Arrangement
that's hold on and two we keep
forgetting it's also on Nintendo switch
yes no PC damn it it was on show us last
year
he's like
oh yeah there's even a network test uh
available soon oh no yeah they don't
play though the network tests are
usually horrendous yeah don't judge that
as a fighter I played the network just
last year I was like oh no no no and the
final product was was it was a solid 30.
yeah get your 30 frames on it's a 30 on
but no PC man they don't want to mess
with these monitors they don't want to
I'm surprised man maybe it's just taking
a while to to work on it but that is
interesting yeah I'm surprised that to
me
MLB Yeah question Emma MLB the show is
on at console game pass but it's not on
PC no there's no PC version at all the
PC version yeah whatever
it was not on PC game pass yeah no PC
first in that decision hmm anyway yeah
shout out to jeans man yeah interesting
launch game he said I could save a
certain that that deal pays for at least
four teams entire payroll you talking
about that MLB look I'll jump in um this
is huge this is huge obviously I'm a
huge MLB the Show fan you know when it
was exclusive to PlayStation that was
the definitive simulation baseball
experience that I love I remember
speaking to Phil vividly you know 2015
2016 when is Xbox going to get the
simulation baseball game and he looked
at Aaron and Aaron looked at me like
that license cost money stop bothering
us but uh but Phil definitely had to
look like no we gonna look into it so
for me this is for the fields greatest
accomplishments it was you he could not
wait to talk about when that deal aside
and MLB the [__] was coming to Game Pass
he he couldn't wait to let us know so
salute to them I'm so happy yeah because
Sony fans have been eating this is one
of I would literally pick up this game
every year for PlayStation no matter
what whatever is [__] man what
happened what happened they just put you
know the little IOP of that context
thing oh he did this is the missing King
and it shows a picture of my jacket
this is yesterday's prices not today's
price this is an Oreo and a microwave
absolutely absolutely I already know who
did that but um yeah man now this this
is big and I'm sorry you're gonna say
something I'm sorry yeah just hey look I
love the show I love the show it is an
amazing simulation I would love to see
some competition oh for sure for sure
for sure they definitely could use
another that's the only thing about the
these like how Madden in the situation
with the NFL I hate when the licensing
is locked to only one but I don't know
if in the MLB well now it seems like now
it probably is locked but um yeah
someone could also use the license and
have a competing game yeah yeah for sure
I mean to me with would seem like you
know the MLB will want as many different
iterations of their game out there so
maybe maybe in the future maybe
something's happening behind the scenes
but I don't know if y'all noticed what's
up and the sizzle reel for the for the
direct yeah they had a big head baseball
power pro baseball that used to come out
it was Japan only we had a few
iterations that came out like on the PS2
during that area and the thing is those
games were always touted for feeling
like like real baseball games but it was
just like you know it but it was you
know big head baseball it wasn't
realistic in that regard
um so they released it it's a Konami
series they released it for I thought it
was just a demo whatever they were
announcing so I went into the ESOP when
I bought a Metroid Prime remastered and
I was like they had it for a dollar and
I'm like what the hell so I'm like it
was a demo or something like that no
it's the full game oh damn for a dollar
so they they're trying to gauge interest
in a different type of baseball game I
downloaded it I played it like it it
feels good to play but it is very much
an online Centric stuff it doesn't have
any any season mode or anything like
that it's very Bare Bones but the
gameplay is what I remember from Power
Pros which is like you play it you're
like oh this feels good to play it kind
of It kind of reminds you and look of
like a polygon version of RBI Baseball
something like that okay no I gotta
check it out I gotta check it out I mean
you know for me like I said I'm all
about the simulation I'm all about the
realism MLB the shoulder with the beauty
of the series is the configurability you
could play the pitching the fielding and
all these different styles that suit to
you that you could get comfortable with
right and then it's the Nuance the
Cinematic feel the camera cuts the
broadcast level the nuances the crowd
specific things the the little things
you know Button getting the guy over and
just the way the ball trajects like I'm
that guy like I love physics and that it
feels real I don't necessarily want uh
you know NFL Blitz kind of thing all the
time yeah that's why that high heat
basically remember that I got that field
yeah they got that but that that license
cost while breading it yeah but you have
to really build from you it's a lot you
got to commit to that you know what I'm
saying so I got to give Sony credit for
that you know those guys what is it Sony
San Diego Santa Monica who is it that
makes sense San Diego San Diego yeah
they did they did that but look back on
point legal League's huge huge uh shout
out to Ramon Russell shout out to the
team you know this is what I want to see
because I think as a kid like learning
about the game learning about the
history you know sometimes it's got like
how kids move explained it like we're
going to Cooperstown like that's dope
like more people should do that the only
thing I remember me as a kid like I used
to shut away from like museums
educational but if you you trick the kid
by giving them the medicine in the form
of a video game right yes then it could
kind of land and I think VR also does a
good job of that as well and I love
stuff like this where it's like okay
here's the history of the game and a
seasonal format obviously Legends Jackie
Robinson statue page all that stuff oh
Josh Gibson yeah yeah I was surprised no
Larry Dolby I was surprised yeah which
was the second African-American uh
player but the first of the American
League that's Jackie Robinson so look
this is dope and I'm I'm kind of
embarrassing this stuff I don't even
know about the full you know process
that's about the uh about the Negro
League so I'm really looking forward to
this big time okay is the person that
played that movie with the dude who
played Black Panther is he in this yeah
because he played Jackie Robinson so
yeah Chadwick Boseman who played Jackie
Robinson that was a good movie yeah
Jackie Robinson is going to be in and
I'm gonna do it so it's like a almost
like a seasonal story mode like I look
at it in a way where I get teaching
moment you can learn what's going on and
let's be honest this was an important
part of America's history where it was
there was segregation in baseball so
yeah this is due and these are the
unsung heroes that you don't know about
so salute to them doing it you see a lot
of them and a lot of them were like
exemplary players
Satchel Paige their stories about
Satchel Paige telling his entire team to
sit down that he was going to strike
everybody out and
the fight yeah okay
it just it there you know Josh Gibson
the you know the the Babe Ruth just do
that like oh we're done we're like bro
the stories you learned and you like wow
this is again just to get the history
this watching that interview with Ramon
Russell and I've got a gentleman's name
who's who who's now kind of the uh
Hendricks yeah the curator of the the
Museum of the Negro League like to learn
these stories this Bob Ken yes that you
didn't know so I can't wait man I'm
excited it's a great educational tool
and just add a little extra value for
MLB to show this year I like watching
those movies I have a feeling if I was
into the sports games I would probably
watch it yeah I mean play it yeah I
guess I'll just play the season mode
just to see what what it's like that's
why I thought my only thing I would I
would say if you just download it just
just play like one season of the day
because to be honest with you they've
got it to the point at it you could put
the controls where everything is like
one button and then like you don't have
to do no complex anything you can you
can make it very arcady for yourself
yeah like it's still it's yeah it's just
for the story aspect of the historical
part I would just recommend it but yeah
that's pretty much all I got salute to
MLB The Show for doing that salute to uh
my man Rebel Russell in the team I
thought that was super dope but that's
what I got let's get the super chance
get up out of here then I'll do the poll
you don't got too much more let's see
let's see I think I got that everything
be good yeah we didn't get any more Okay
cool so I'll do the poll oh wait hold on
my apologies no we have
uh Lord Metroid Zelda's one of the
greatest oh no oh no hold on shout out
to um Powers he said
died today yeah from De La Soul
oh rest in peace that was my Miz that's
crazy plug one plug two and all that
damn that's crazy that's what's up um
that's crazy yeah we're caught our
caught up all right let's get the pulled
in all right with the overall success of
the Nintendo switch third best console
Sonic console of all time but recently
The Chronic numbers in the last quarter
what do you think is the right decision
for Nintendo regarding their current
Hardware a status quo switch can still
exist and continue to be successful in
its current state B switch is showing
its age it needs a pro like upgrade at
minimum
see Nintendo needs to release their next
Generation platform or date I don't care
the Zelda Tyrant Kingdom amiibos better
not be seventy dollars also shoot out to
the team everybody's gonna support us
that was super messy oh shout out to the
team it'll be up there on the iron Lords
podcast Twitter account I see the rest
of pieces for True [__] man yeah salute
salute to the realm for that that's love
but um yeah I'm absolute two big time
Maca who came through salute 2 again K
Asanti the muffin man and of course kids
move we'll see if they have dipped away
for a little bit I was gonna give them a
shout out but uh attic man where can I
find peacoatic where can I find people
find you what you got going on I'm gonna
start wearing this every week it's
Friday I like you in there
with that that you gonna have to come to
the game
is I got like a big leather coat in my
closet that I'd rather put on because
it's heavy heavy we got a fedora yeah
but I appreciate it for coming through
um we add up to like I think it was like
600 some people in here uh it's a nice
nice show uh you can catch me on Twitter
at Lord addict IOP catch me on YouTube a
gaming addict and uh don't forget to go
in
follow uh R and R with the Lord we we do
a show every every Tuesday at one uh 5
PM
huh see like you're grabbing chips or
something oh no no okay but I appreciate
for coming through and we'll see you
next week I appreciate you bro for
coming through and of course Lord solve
preaching The Sovereign the sermons
today everyone's standing and clapping
every time Saul speaks
uh you can find me at work and not enjoy
the Super Bowl unfortunately but you're
not it is what it is uh shout out to
everybody came through today man big
vodka Big Time Walker is hilarious yeah
that's like again it's good to see that
kind of energy online I always love to
see that and of course shout out to
smooth and to K Asante and the muffet
man coming through a shout out to the
brother King I hope he's feeling yeah
yeah King King King
can't make it King wasn't feeling well
yeah yeah that's that
um what else hopefully I'll play some
more uh Hogwarts this week at that
smooth 40 on that steam deck until I get
my laptop in so I can throw on the ray
tracing and all the craziness
um and that's more Metroid yes and
that's about it but yeah check out r r
check out what addict and King are doing
um check out the reactions they're doing
like the reactions are hilarious to like
you know big moments in certain shows
and stuff like that that stuff is
hilarious and this is all from The
Mastermind of Atticus is the one behind
the scenes sort of machinating making
this stuff happens we just check it out
we just King just reacted to the female
Titan versus Levi and Attack on Titan
the first time they fought nice they
salute the king man says love to him no
doubt kids move sets of love to Planet X
Box the best spot I know he stepped away
but he was rocking with us for a long
time so he's allowed yeah and again
salute everybody that pulled up man Big
Time Market salute man funny enjoy
myself you know what I'm saying good to
see him you know get a little light get
a little shine and uh we'll see the
shows on that and we got a lot of fun
things cooking you know telling y'all
right now we're sitting on some things
stay tuned to the realm this is where
you definitely don't want to miss out
should we tell them about the interview
or or let's let them find out next week
just stay tuned stay tuned stay tuned
next week you guys are going to want to
be there for that pre-show we'll be
starting soon screen yeah no doubt oh
man super chat came in real quick
Nintendo the otaku five dollar Super
Chat great show even with the biased
one-sided ganging up on Nintendo with no
one from the Nintendo Community to push
back you're part of the Nintendo
Community I know what's funny is I've
reviewed a lot of Nintendo games that's
the crazy part and I rarely tell you not
to buy a Nintendo game uh look
[Laughter]
at our agenda salute to you brother
you'll be going hard for Nintendo and
I'm I'm glad at least we we got some
topics for the bag
well they go kid there we go kid where
can the five people find what you got
going on about to head out my bad my bad
you could find me on YouTube at kids
smooth Twitter at kids smooth uh uh do I
got anything major coming back going on
nah just playing this uh Hogwarts um
playing Xbox
um doing that just move that to um
Saturday so I'll resume for the year
um and man I I don't really I'm gonna
try to get a video out because I know I
don't got to do weapon world tonight so
just to have something oh yeah I was
wondering
I was like BG please I was like I hope
he ain't doing that okay and the bonds
team is in it so oh yeah the Phillies
ABG Philly fan too yeah Eagles fan yeah
fake Philly fans
he ain't no real actual Philippines he
had two different teams this year so and
so I'm a I'm a watcher just for the
commercials I got a quick question I
don't know if anybody asked this but uh
what are the chances we see a star field
ad today
that'll be interesting I will say we
probably hope maybe we hopefully hear
from this tall field soon because they
got to do the show right they got to do
a show but I just don't think those
Superman Super Bowl thing what I'm
hearing down the Grapevine we won't have
to wait longer yeah hopefully we get a
show yeah we're getting a Flash trailer
we're getting uh what the heck that's
what we're getting some couple of
trailers oh Little Mermaid for that
that's something else for people to be
angry about yeah
let's let's go down that path though
um another Super Chat that we're about
here okay we got Lord Metroid I'm here
Don I got you back switch gig coming in
high I see y'all should have salute the
Lloyd Metroid salute to Nintendo on
having some Nintendo topics showing the
love I see y'all oh next what's up wake
up when are we good trying to do that
Round Table podcast because we're just
gonna do it live since it's a community
event oh yeah yeah we can figure it out
on the latest Saturday oh we're gonna
happen if we do it early Saturday
because um we got a we got a Quantum
Mania on Saturday oh yeah we do it like
one Saturday can't we no no that's
pushing it because then we got to join
it what time is it to the corner minute
three we'll figure out hey we'll talk
offline yeah yeah anyway
we're talking about this on the job
everybody enjoy your Sunday again stay
tuned stay tuned to the patreon stay
tuned to the community on the channel
just stay tuned we got stuff cooking for
y'all trust me yeah everybody have a
good weekend peace you guys gonna love
next week
all right
foreign
[Music]